So ich bin noch mal da mir war langweilig wusste ich was ich heute abend noch machen soll ich bin gedacht ich mache jetzt einfach noch mal streamern
Ich hätte jetzt wahrscheinlich, oh moment headset kabel was ist da los
Sack so ja keine ahnung was ich da getrieben habe ich bin mit dem stuhl über das kabel gefahren
Ja wahrscheinlich hätte ich jetzt eh noch ein bisschen youtube geguckt oder irgendwie amazon irgendwie was geguckt oder sowas habe ich mir gedacht
wir machen jetzt einfach den stream noch mal an guckt zusammen was
ja bettke
wie gesagt heute high iq 3 hat bettke stream
ich warte ja drauf dass irgendwelche leute sagen max 3 hat ist nicht high iq
aber dafür sind meine leute zu high iq die erkennen dass ich jetzt absichtlich zum tschibaden den titel geschrieben habe
Alternativ ist der titel auch so unverständlich dass es niemand checkt was ich überhaupt will das ist auch möglichkeit aber dann haben wir nicht genug
prime subs
haben wir uns letzten schon angeguckt
haben wir uns letzten schon angeguckt allerdings was wir uns nur am rande
angeguckt ja haben wir gemacht bevor wir dann battlefield gespielt haben
was wir uns nur am rande angeguckt haben
ist das hier
also die anderen sachen haben uns alle angeguckt
allerdings das hier haben wir uns nur nur ganz kurz angeguckt weil ich wollte ein bisschen battlefield spiel heute nicht
und was ich wieder sehr interessant fand ist dass rust
eigentlich kaum gebraucht wird oder sagen wir mal so
relativ wenig gebraucht wird
und sehr beliebt ist was ich was ich jetzt persönlich ein bisschen
was ein bisschen merkwürdig finde ist warum
warum
warum es die sharp hier nur bei 21 ist das ist eines der beliebtesten sprachen so genau check ich die statistik nicht
es ist eines der beliebtesten sprachen und es ist eines der
mitgefragtesten
weiß ich nicht aber go go ist auch da unten irgendwo nur rust nur auf rust stehen sie total
ja matlab oder mathlab oder wie auch immer das will keiner machen
groovy ist für den arsch das benutzt keiner mehr
was auch noch sehr beliebt ist ist raku ich habe seriöslich keine ahnung was raku language überhaupt sein soll
Kobol ist null designed und wenig admired also eigentlich auch für den arsch
f-sharp wundert mich nicht dass es
Funktionale sprachen sind erfreuen sich teilweise einer großen beliebtheit gd script was ist denn gd script
ist das ist das ist das für diese für diese eine game engine
in d script
Ja ist für die game engine wusste ich gerade nicht wie die heißt aber ja die die meinte ich
Ja
typescript auch klar aber rust rust ist mal wieder voll oben mit dabei
Und es wird von jahr zu jahr habe ich den eindruck auch begehrter leute zu finden die was mit rust können wobei es immer noch nicht
zu vergleichen ist mit
Mit anderen sachen also und das glaube ich auch nicht
Dass das rust irgendwie mal oben bei den desired sprachen mit ankommen wird dafür ist rust einfach nicht breit genug
Naja gut man kann nicht sagen breit genug anwendbar das ist es aber nicht aber nicht für breit genuge sachen wirklich
wirklich gedacht und gemacht und geeignet ja
Man kann es aber prinzipiell alles mit rust machen allerdings rust scheint halt gerade an der stelle wo es
so schnell wie möglich sein muss und
zur compile zeit so oder generell nicht nur zur compile zeit und
So also so schnell wie möglich und soweit memory safe wie möglich und das ganze ohne dass es irgendeine managed runtime hat
Ne ne das ist aktuell
Moin
Dafür ist rust gut zum beispiel wenn man eine css engine bauen will oder eine irgendwie
html render engine für einen browser oder so wo das ja übrigens auch herkommt vom mozilla
Dann mag das sinnvoll sein für so eine 0815 windows ui anwendung ist jetzt rust vielleicht nicht das sinnvollste
Da ist bei der anderen programmier sprachen deutlich schneller und und zielstrebiger unterwegs als jetzt mit rust
Und ich finde auch für game engines
Beziehungsweise dort irgendwelche sachen super eignet sich rust jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig gut weil ganz im ernst du brauchst
Zwar die performance von rust dort okay, aber du brauchst diese ganze memory safety von rust sagen wir mal
Es ist nice allerdings nicht unter der prämisse dass die entwicklungszeit dadurch ziemlich steigt
Also weil bei einem game game ist ja meistens nicht security oder nicht sicherheits relevant ist im schlimmsten fall
Crasht ihr halt das game so was ja davon ist eine festplatte nicht formatiert danach oder hast keine mailware drauf
habt ihr schon mal
Nein, haben wir nicht haben wir nicht
unsere machine learning experience hält sich noch ziemlich in grenzen
Leute mir fällt gerade auf ich sehe es gerade hier drüben auf bildschirm ich habe seit seit seit über zwei wochen kein video mehr gemacht
Und eigentlich wollte ich ein battlefield video machen aber ich weiß nicht ob sich das überhaupt noch lohnt jetzt nach dem season 5 ja auch
Wieder zwei wochen raus ist oder eine woche vorbei ist
nicht sie sind doch sie sind fünf
ich weiß nicht
Databases ja gut postgres postgres ohne scheiß postgres hat es verdient postgres ist der der also hier wisst ihr was man hier an sieht
Hier an sieht man wie es was es ausmacht wenn man jahrelang einfach das macht was die leute sich wünschen in einem projekt
Postgres ist hat sich durchgesetzt ist mit die beliebteste datenbank
Und es ist aber auch also nicht nur die begehrteste datenbank sondern auch die
Beliebteste datenbank wird bloß noch von ok redis ja gut
Ok redis hier ist die haben ja alles reingeschmissen ja
Super base die haben ja alles reingekriegt duck db noch nie gehört
Dynamo db ist die asia geschichte das ist dass die firebase das ist quasi dieser aufsatz auf google cloud
Elastik ist noch irgendwas beliebter als
Postgres
Datomic noch nie gehört wie hieß eigentlich noch mal diese datenbank die vor einem dreiviertel jahr oder so
Schlagzeilen gemacht hat
Dass dass die beste datenbank aller zeiten werden soll und sie kann alles besser als alle schon bestehenden datenbanken
Wie hieß das ding der noch mal surreal db genau
Gibt es gibt es gibt es das überhaupt noch die haben es ja die haben ja auch mit ein bisschen übertreibung da sind die
Eingestiegen ok ich habe nichts gesagt aber blazingly fast written in rust
Postgres kann viele coole sachen postgres kann mittlerweile ganz brauchbar timeseries und postgres kann fulltext search und
Postgres kann trigram search also du kannst sowas wie auto complete wunderbar mit postgres bauen und
Teilstring suche und sowas postgres ist einfach high IQ shit passt ja heute zum stream
Das taucht hier drinne schon mal gar nicht auf surreal db
Ja das bringt ja aber für teilstring suche nix
Aber genau ich wollte gerade sagen demonstrieren wir
Cloudplatforms was ist denn am beliebtesten hetzer und versailles ok hetzer tatsächlich
Ja ein bisschen ein bisschen unfair ist es ja irgendwo schon für beide seiten jetzt weil
Selbstverständlich ist AWS, Azure und Google
Deutlich mehr desired als hetzer mal ganz ehrlich niemand hat als anforderung an irgendeine stellen anzeige
Ja kenne ich ein bisschen mit hetzer aus aber da muss man auch sagen hetzer ist easy zu benutzen
Und kann halt bei weitem nicht das was azure oder google oder aws können aber dafür was es kann kann es ziemlich gut
Und ist easy zu benutzen das heißt ich kann das voll und ganz verstehen also ich finde
Von den ganzen cloud anbietern die ich bisher gesehen habe hat hetzer eindeutig das angenehmste webinterface
Aber man muss halt auch wie gesagt
Sagen sie können halt nur einen ganz ganz kleinen bruchteil von dem was was größere daten was
Größere cloud anbieter können oder auch was digital ocean kann digital ocean hat zumindest ein managed kubernetes managed datenbanken alles mögliche
Und hetzer hat eigentlich in anführungsstrichen nur
vms und seit einem jahr oder so oder zwei
loadbalancer
Das war es
Das ist natürlich schon unterschied zu sowas wie beispielsweise google cloud die einfach alles in irgendeiner art und weise haben von
Managed prometheus bis managed datenbanken bis managed kubernetes bis
Einfach container run geschichten public pub sub message queues die haben alles
hetzer hat halt
Wenig aber das was sie haben haben sie sehr gut
Bleier ist auch relativ beliebt die haben die haben quasi einen steilen aufschwung auf flug was auch immer
Okay, ich lasse es ich wollte etwas lustiges sagen, aber ich gebe zu ich gebe zu das hat nicht funktioniert
Bleier ist relativ beliebt die gibt es noch nicht so lang richtig massive pains ja ich gebe es ja zu aber
Die hatten ein paar probleme in letzter zeit zum beispiel hatten die ersten größere datenbank ausfall
Wo dann nix mehr funktioniert hatten wo sie dann auch so einen blog post geschrieben haben dass die probleme mit ihrer postkast datenbank hatten
Oracle cloud infrastructure das kann ich nicht verstehen dass es immer noch so weit entmeiert ist
Weil gerade was ich lese was oracle und free tier angeht ist ziemlich überschisst die sagen free tier du kriegst
Du kriegst eine richtig fette vm vier kerne 8g ram oder sonst was in der richtung umsonst
Bloß dass die random einfach die die vms terminaten von leute die komplett im free tier sind und nix und nix
Ja, so kann man auch die leute verkrauen aber ganz im ernst mich wundert bei oracle nix mehr das ist eines der größten
scheißläden ever
Hetzner will das ich würde sagen hetzner kann das auch gar nicht so ohne weiteres machen
Wollen tun die sicherlich noch einiges was im cloud umfeld passieren soll aber
Es macht auch keinen sinn
Also sie können es einfach auch nicht einfach auf aus dem boden stampfen ich hoffe ja drauf das habe ich damals ja auch
Mal mal vorgeschlagen wobei da war ich sicherlich nicht der erste
Ich habe den ja auch mal vorgeschaut wie wäre es dann wirklich
Mit einer managed datenbank das würde das würde viele wirklich denke ich sehr freuen wenn sie die datenbank genügend nicht selbst hosten
Okay, ich sage mal so hetzner hat ja eine managed datenbank aber also die haben in ihrem webhosting eine managed mysql
Aber das meine ich nicht
Ich meine eher was in richtung cloud sql wie bei google
Was ist denn die stacket cloud und was ist heroku ist auch richtig abgekackt
Die waren mega beliebt zu ruby on rails zeiten das war ich würde mal sogar behaupten heroku war
Der erste oder mit der erste cloud anbieter den man überhaupt so nennen kann sie waren ganz früh dabei
Guck mal mal
2012 oder so die waren die gibts 2007 die gibt es schon richtig lang aber die haben auch den anschluss ein bisschen verpasst das
war so der erste richtig cloud anbieter nicht so richtig mitbekommen habe aber die haben dann halt
Die trenn so ein bisschen verschlafen auch die haben glaube ich lange zeit auch rails only gemacht
Ja und genau und irgendwann das kommt auch aber irgendwann haben sie ihr free tier haben sie leute aus dem free tier raus geworfen
und dann war halt f
Da haben sich ein paar schon ein eigentor geschossen was free tier free tier einstellen geht ja
Also da fällt mir da fällt mir natürlich
Heroku natürlich die haben sich ins bein geschossen
Cloud mqtt hat sich auch ein bisschen ins bein geschossen
und ganz prominent
docker
docker hat sich auch ziemlich ins eigene bein geschossen mit ihrer geschichte
Keiner soll kann mehr kostenlos ordentlich die sachen hosten und also ganz ehrlich ich weiß eh nicht was die firma hinter docker docker treibt
Die hatten eigentlich die lizenz zum gelddrucken und haben es irgendwie nicht hinbekommen
Der letzte ausweg war dann die firma noch für ein paar millionen verkaufen noch ein bisschen kohle rauszuschlagen
Und was der neue eigentümer mit docker treibt ist auch also generell die firma was die firma in die jetzige firma hinter docker treibt ist
Einfach nur noch wir als erstes haben sie ja quasi ihr free free
free
Registry so weit runter gedreht dass sie kaum noch ordentlich benutzen kann
Und jetzt kam sie mal letztens auf die idee wir machen auch die ganzen orga sachen kostenpflichtig das haben sie dann aber wieder zurück
Zurückgerudert weil das problem dabei ist gewesen also zum beispiel ja
Docker hub nehmen wir mal ubuntu als als beispiel oder oder keine ahnung
Next cloud als beispiel so da gibt es ja halt
Next cloud ist ein blödes beispiel
Also es gibt ja ein paar offizielle images die auf docker hub gehostet werden allerdings
Nicht alle organisationen benutzen das regelmäßig es gibt
Organisationen die haben sich zum beispiel einfach nur diesen namespace registriert ja also stellt euch mal vor ihr habt ein semi erfolgreiches
Keine ahnung nehmen wir den vm champ
so
stellt euch mal vor
Moment geht's ab
Stellt euch mal vor ich würde davon jetzt ein offizielles docker image anbieten wollen
Das ist so ein bisschen bisschen beliebt so es gibt drei image drei achso der phipps hat noch aufgemacht
Also das ist jetzt ein
Minimal beliebtes github projekt vielleicht und ich sage mal ich will dafür ein offizielles image anbieten in zukunft ein offizielles docker image
Aber jetzt noch nicht erst wenn ich vielleicht noch ein paar sachen eingebaut habe dann könnte ich mir jetzt hier beispielsweise so eine die
die vm champ orga oder vm champ projekt
grub was auch immer registrieren
Und das haben einige organisationen gemacht die benutzen das gar nicht regelmäßig aber jetzt hat docker gesagt
Jeder bezahlt doch mal für und da haben viele open source projekte gesagt ja nee
Wir verdienen damit kein geld und außerdem benutzen wir es gar nicht aber wir haben es mal wir haben es mal
Reserviert weil und jetzt kommt ja der trick dabei stellt euch mal vor ihr habt ein semi erfolgreiches
Github projekt oder sagen wir mal irgendwas im bereich von 1000 sternen so irgendeine
Github organisation mit ein paar erfolgreichen projekten so und ihr habt die auf docker hab registriert und jetzt heißt es ihr müsst was bezahlen
Ihr sagt ich bezahle nichts
Weil ich verdiene damit kein geld und will auch kein geld für bezahlen müssen und dann
registriert sich irgendjemand anderes irgendwelche china chinesen malware verbreiter unter dem namen eures github projektes
Und bietet dort manipulierte images zum download an niemand wird das checken die sagen dann alle
docker pull vm champ
Ohne und ohne zu wissen dass es eigentlich in china chinesen image ist
Das ist richtig bescheuert gewesen was docker sich da überlegt hat mit diesem ihr müsst jetzt bezahlen oder werden rausgeschmissen
Zum glück zum glück haben sie noch mal zurück gerudert
Ja und die haben einige solcher dinger getrieben die firma hinter docker deswegen ganz im ernst
Ich die hatten also die ursprüngliche docker firma hatte so die lizenz zum geld rocken haben es nicht geschafft
Haben eher so komische dinger wie docker swarm versucht was ehrlich gesagt viel zu spät gekommen ist da war der ganze andere kram schon schon
Tja im im entstehen und sowas sie haben durch ihre
free tier einschränkungen dafür gesorgt dass andere container registries überhaupt erst relevant geworden sind
Leute es gab keine github container registry keine google container registry keine
Azure container registry und sonst was der zeit lang weil docker hub war einfach super zuverlässig und jeder konnte es verwenden und jeder hatte genug
hatte genug free tier und alles
Und erst als docker hub auf die idee gekommen ist oder als die
Firma hinter docker auf die idee gekommen ist zu sagen aber wir strecken das free tier zu krass ein dann sind die ganzen kontenten die
Anderen externen container registries aus dem boden gesprossen
Also die sind selber schuld dass sie so in der in der bedeutungslosigkeit am versinken sind
Das einzige was noch wirklich relevanz hat und auch relevant bleiben wird
Ist halt docker an sich das wird nicht von heute auf morgen verschwinden weil ganz im ernst ich finde es ist immer noch das beste
user command line user interface für container krempel
Und auch zum lokalen
Images bauen und sowas wobei es da immer mehr alternativen gibt dass du für viele sachen gar kein docker mehr brauchst aber für lokales
Container image ausführen ist docker eigentlich immer noch am besten
Ja ganz ehrlich ich bin der meine pop man hat es nicht wirklich gebraucht ja nice okay
Du kannst die container ohne gutrechte ausführen das ist schon nicht schlecht warum das warum sind aber docker so lange für brauchen verstehe
Ich auch nicht wobei ich glaube das geht ja theoretisch sogar mittlerweile aber keiner benutzt
Was aber auch nicht so schlimm ist weil es im lokale entwicklungscontainer meistens geht
Naja gut jetzt habe ich euch erst mal voll geschwätzt zehn minuten jetzt dürft ihr auch wieder was sagen
So was haben wir denn sonst noch heute ich muss mal ein bisschen entspannteres wuppwuppwupp machen
Können die sich mal entscheiden
Hat jemand eine langfristige zuverlässige empfehlung für einen domain registriert wo google domains weg ist cloudflare kann keine die ja das ist halt richtig kacke
Ich gucke regelmäßig nach aber die können es immer noch nicht
Reddit empfiehlt gandhi und porgban, porgban habe ich auch ein paar domains
Porgban ist günstig das UI ist auch ganz okay das problem bei porgban ist ein bisschen dass die apis sagt
Die haben zwar mittlerweile der dns api aber die haben beispielsweise keine api um zu gucken wann die domains ablaufen und sowas
Also ich habe domains bei lasst mal überlegen ich habe noch eine ganz alte domain bei
nitrado
Bei nitrado bei name silo habe ich noch welche mal zum ausprobieren gehabt namecheap
Habe ich ein paar liegen
Cloudflare habe ich ein paar liegen
Porgban habe ich ein paar liegen warum so viele domains also warum ich bei so vielen domain registrars bin
Okay name silo war rein zum ausprobieren die domains lasse ich auslaufen der rest hat sich hat sich so ergeben so die letzten jahre über
Kenne ich nicht ja das blöde bei hetzner ist was domains angeht
Dass man sich damit mit dass man real namen braucht und sowas
Du kannst bei hetzner nicht einfach eintragen
Peter wubbel gehört die domain die wollen dass du belegst dass du peter wubbel bist das ist halt ziemlich
ziemlich
keck weight
Also bei hetzner kannst du dich nicht einfach so registrieren mit fake sachen bei vielen anderen domain registraren geht das also ich bin bei allen
Domain registraren mit fake daten registriert was geht die meine echte adresse und meinen echten namen und und echte telefon und echtes zeug an nix
Manche domain registrar sind der meinung sie müssen für privacy options dass das
Whois abfrage versteckt wird auch noch extra geld verlangt ist mir egal bei mir muss man keine whois abfrage verstecken bei den meisten ist mittlerweile
Inklusive weil ich habe nur fake daten drin stehen
Ja also namecheap habe ich auch ein paar
Porkbun ist aber relativ günstig ich glaube porkbun ist somit der günstigste domain registrar den ich kenne
UI ist ein bisschen pp gar
Was man mal gucken muss haben die mittlerweile eine api für
Nein haben sie immer noch nicht
Sie haben keine api für
domain expire und sowas
Sie haben nur sie haben nur dns api das hatten sie übrigens auch lange nicht habe ich euch mal erzählt dass
dass die mich wegen
Ich nenne es mal ddos gesperrt haben bei porkbun
richtig richtig pp gehalter
Kalendereintrag reicht doch kalendereintrag reicht aber nicht wenn du viele domains hast da blickst du doch nicht mal durch
Hetzer brauchst du leider
real echter name und sowas
Also warum die mich gesperrt haben ist folgendes zu einer zeit als sie noch keine dns records hatten aber ich domains dort hatte habe ich
das folgendermaßen gemacht man kann ja mit thirdboard
Hook
scripts
ranhängen
Also es gibt die möglichkeit dass thirdboard quasi die dns einträge nicht über eine api die also über über eine api die sie unterstützen
verlängert sondern du kannst auch
Erneuerungs hooks und ausstellungs hooks mit thirdboard verwenden also thirdboard ist ein tool da kannst du mittlerweile ein encrypt zertifikate ausstellen für eine domain
Auch für interne domains die nicht public über ttp erreichbar sind so und da habe ich ein paar hooks
Reingebaut mit einem script für porkbun und was das script gemacht hat ist das war ein puppeteer script das hat quasi
Einen browser in der headless browser geöffnet sich eingeloggt über das web interface und dann in dem in dem web ui
Angeklickt dns dns record erstellen und und so zeug ja war richtig richtig hängen geblieben
Muss man so machen weil die damals keine dns api hatten
Und ich habe das halt beim entwickeln ein bisschen zu oft ausgeführt und irgendwann stand halt da ihre ip wurde so blacklisted
Gesperrt was ziemlich doof war weil ich von meiner weil ich von meiner ip daheim ausgemacht habe und dann konnte ich halt mich nicht
Mal einloggen
und mit und mit vodafone
Ist halt auch nicht so einfach eine neue ip zu kommen da musste einmal übernachtet das dsl modem auslassen dann kriegst du
Morgens neue ip zumindest hatten sie mich gesperrt
Macht das mal kurz hier auf weil ein bisschen dark dark reader
So da hatten sie mich hatten sie mich gesperrt und jetzt und jetzt kommt ja der jetzt kommt ja der eigentliche kw moment
Dann habe ich dann habe ich dort an den support geschrieben habe ich sagt ja ja sorry leute ich habe hier eure webseite
Automatisiert und habe ein bisschen zu oft darauf zugegriffen könnt ihr mich noch mal freischreibe
Freischalten hat mir gesagt ja kein problem machen wir aber wir also so automatisierung über die webseite
Mögen sie nicht soll es doch sein lassen habe ich gesagt okay ich lasse es sein
Und jetzt kommt der hit
Ich habe dann ein bisschen weiter an der automatisierung gebaut allerdings nicht für pork bun
Sondern ich habe browser automatisierung gebaut für irgendwas anderes
Und ich habe eine domain vergesse ich habe die pork bun domain vergessen auszutauschen
Und auf einmal habe ich das ausgeführt mal wieder geploppt
Und da muss ich dir noch mal schreiben also ich habe mich verklickt
Ich habe mich vertan ich hatte eure domain noch drin stehen könnt ihr mich noch mal freischalten
Ich glaube drittes mal hätten sie mich nicht mehr freigeschaltet
Aber haben sie gemacht also support technisch hat es bei denen auch ganz gut funktioniert
Leider haben die keine
Domain expiry und sowas dass das wäre doch wirklich sehr nice
Die haben nur aber immerhin haben sie jetzt offizielle dns apis das ist doch schon mal was
kein expiry date
Der support hat sicherlich ziemlich kacke w als ich es denen erzählt habe
Cloudflare hat das problem cloudflare unterstützt keine die domains ich weiß nicht warum um ehrlich zu sein
Es ist richtig hängen geblieben hätten würde ohne scheiß hätte cloudflare die domains ich hätte wahrscheinlich alle meine domains bei cloudflare
Gebündelt mittlerweile und fertig aus aber aus irgendwelchen gründen
Hat cloudflare keine die domain und ich weiß nicht ob sie es jemals bekommen werden ja richtig strange ich weiß auch nicht warum
Was machst du mit den ganzen domains haben warum muss es in die domain sein hier weil es halt
Weil ich schon die domains habe
Es müssen jetzt wenn sie neu sind müssen die unbedingt die e sein aber ich habe halt schon die domains
Warum sollte ich die warum sollte ich die weg und warum sollte ich die
Abgeben zippt umher und ich höre mal bloß auf ja das ist auch sehr pock emoji top level domain
Was machst du mit den ganzen hey ich hoffe ja mal dass irgendwelche domains richtig viel asche noch wert werden also manche sind sogar
schon ein bisschen was wert
Aber so ist so irgendwie
50.000 oder so 100.000 plus für den domain so welche war ich leider nicht früh genug dabei beim registrieren
Aber ich habe ich habe investiert in domains
Schon vor langer zeit mal gucken vielleicht zahlt sich es ja irgendwann noch mal richtig aus
Kostet auch nicht viel zu verlängern
Ne so eine habe ich nicht
Ich hätte ich hätte damals
1998 oder sowas so die üblichen verdächtigen 6.de oder sowas hätte ich registrieren müssen die hätte ich für millionen verkaufen können
Das ist gut das ist eine gute domain
Übrigens wisst ihr was ich gesehen habe bei set servers
Set servers da gibt es eine umfrage wenn man jetzt sich da aufmacht oder wenn man die seite aufmacht und zwar
Die wollen einen linux
Problemfix world cup ausrichten da sind wir dabei oder sollte das stattfinden
der linux der linux admin die linux admin
weltmeisterschaft quasi
Ich weiß nicht ob das jemals dazu dazu ob das jemals stattfinden wird ja
Ist auch es ist noch nichts es ist noch nichts dazu bekannt
Aber die idee finde ich cool ich meine wir waren also hier hat man schon mal gesehen ganz so schlecht sind für nichts
gibt es eigentlich was neues
Ganz so schlecht sind wir ja nicht wir werden bestimmt nicht gewinnen aber mitmachen würde ich
Ich finde das übrigens gar nicht so abwegig es gibt es gibt auch jede menge
competitive programming geschichte
competitive
ctf und und sonstige sachen
warum nicht warum nicht
competitive linux server fixen
Ohne guckt ihr das nicht an php hat mich so abgefuckt das gibt es das gibt es jetzt schon
das gibt es also passt mal auf
Also als erstes ich zeige ich zeige euch jetzt mal drei oder
Zwei zwei esports wo ihr nicht dachte dass es die gibt ja das erste ist
Landwirtschafts
Simulator
esport
Ich lasse jetzt mal die drops fallen
Wir haben auch schon spiele gesehen wo spieler exakt unter der drohne gelaufen sind und darauf gewartet haben
Teilweise eine minute oder mehr da zwei herangehensweisen von von teams die einen
kalkulieren damit und brauchen einen bestimmten job unbedingt und den anderen ist es eigentlich relativ egal und die rechnen das gar nicht so in ihrer
Strategie mit ein wenn es dann klappt klappt es aber wenn nicht da sind sie gerade
Was haben wir haben den boost
Wieder gebustet so dann gibt es noch die exe weltmeisterschaft schon bereit
Na
Microsoft exel world championship finals gibt es auch
Hält man nicht für möglich aber gibt es
Zum
Und jetzt kommt das worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte wenn ihr mal nach competitive programming guckt
Der dude alter der geht der geht übertrieben der typ geht übertrieben ab hier
Guckt ihr müsst euch das mal angucken zwischendurch passt auf passt auf
obviously
Aber
Da sieht man die wim only keine autocompletion nix
einfach nur
raw wim c++
Aber der ist richtig krass der kerl
Der ist
Der ist richtig hart drauf ja das sind drei drei e-sports die ihr nicht denkt dass es die gibt
Das wäre auch ein gutes videotitel oder
so was in der richtung
Drei drei e-sports von denen ihr nicht denkt dass es sie gibt da braucht man natürlich einen schöneren
Schöneren clickbait titel dafür aber wäre ich mal ein ganz gutes thema aber dazu müsst ihr erst mal videos aufnehmen
Das macht ja nix wichtig ist dass das ergebnis stimmt bei solchen competitive programming geschichten
Ob du es lesen kannst oder nicht ist zweitrangig
Muss schnell sein also muss schnell programmiert sein und das ergebnis liefern dann ist gut twitch chat championship
Ja gut also wenn es um twitch chat iq geht wenn so eine twitch chat
Five head meisterschaft gebe da werden wir definitiv vorne mit dabei
Leute ich sage es ja immer wieder ich habe den intelligentesten twitch chat
Und umso mehr prime subs umso mehr eq punkte das steht außer frage aber jetzt war ohne ohne spaß ich glaube ich habe wirklich
Einer der schlauesten high IQ exten
twitch chats die es gibt
Welche bereiche arbeiten du meinst den du meinst den competitive programmer
Ich glaube aktuell studiert er gerade informatik am
MIT quasi da wo gordon freeman auch studiert hat
Ja meiner schon twitch im allgemeinen nicht aber hier ist schon massive brain
Wann machst du den chat iq test machen lassen
Wenn du das so schreiben kannst dass das ein richtiger satz ist
Okay, ich bin recht schreibt flames sind immer so echt unterste gürtellinie recht schreibt flames kann jeder
Zumal ich ja nicht mal selbst richtig schreiben kann also der typ wie gesagt ich glaube der studiert gerade am mit
Informatik und ich glaube er hat er nicht sogar irgendwie ein google praktikum oder sowas schon am start also der ist richtig
richtiger mindset
high-performer
Um so sachen wie templo es programmieren zu können da brauchst du zwei sachen
Du musst richtig richtig fein verzeihen schon fast sechs hat und du musst komplett verrückt sein
Also also krankhaft gestört sein dann geht das
Und die kombination das war ja bei dem typ bei dem templo es typ so
Der war der war komplett durch im kopf aber sechs hat
katze katze chico chico
Okay, leute ich brauche
Mein headset tut weh am ohr
Okay, leute ich glaube ich brauche neue neue ohrenpolster fürs headset die sind aber auch schon ein bisschen älter
Das eine ist jetzt ist ein bisschen kaputt und der rand der kratzt richtig am ohr wenn man es nicht richtig gerade aufzieht
Du wirst dich wundern
Wie viele leute an dem programmieren also an den an den programmieren in der berufsschule
An dem programmierunterricht gescheitert sind und der war wirklich einfach
Chat ratet mal vielleicht habe ich das ja schon erzählt was meint ihr was das
Schwierigste oder wie weit wir gekommen sind in drei jahren programmieren in der berufsschule bis was sind wir gekommen
Also was ist das was ist das advanceste was wir gemacht haben
Was ist eine klappe so?
Das wäre ja schon was nein nein nein
Richtig richtig
Richtig funktion mehr haben wir nicht geschafft
Also das was wir in drei jahren berufsschule geschafft haben war
Macht man ein if macht man eine schleife macht man eine funktion fertig ohne scheiß das war es drei jahre berufsschule
Das war wirklich lächerlich das war so schlecht
Und okay man muss man muss eine sache noch ein bisschen zur rettung der berufsschule sagen es war ja datenbanken und programmieren in einem
Aber trotzdem in datenbanken war war ein join das ist das komplizierteste was wir gemacht haben glaube ich
Ja also ohne scheiß berufsschule war so
Unglaublich easy programmieren das das war es war einfach lächerlich
Oh, ja
Wann warst du in der schule wann warst du in der berufsschule hier
Also jantari war in der gleichen berufsschule wie ich
Wir waren beiden wir waren beide in der
optisch sicherlich schönsten
berufsschule überhaupt
Okay, bei dir ich war ich war 2007 da ja also die also wirklich die mit
Abstand
So eine angefackelte treppe alter ja also die mit abstand optisch
hübscheste berufsschule überhaupt die beispielsweise auch matratzen von pennern vor der
Vor der tür hand ja
Ist es nicht nice
overhead projektor
2018 war das noch
Gute gute overhead projektor am start wie im knast ist es auch
Die schule sieht aus wie ein knast warum auch immer das
Das forder bringt mich immer wieder zum lachen wenn ich das sehe
Berufsschule ist wirklich echt
Absoluter
Streck gewesen so also in dreck vom und aber auch von vom unterricht der
klassenraum wie
1998 alter der eingang sieht schon so aus als willst du da nicht raus
Als willst du nur noch raus und nicht rein
Die berufsschule
Zumindest hat sich anscheinend der unterricht ein bisschen verbessert wenn ihr wenn ihr in c sharp schon
Jua ist gemacht haben so soweit sind wir nicht gekommen gibt es den herr
Lass mal überlegen wen hatte ich wen hatte ich in
In datenbanken und programmieren den herr kapas glaube ich hieß der typ hat das zu den auch wen hattest du jantarien hat das zu
programmieren
Ich glaube kappes hieß der typ
Michael kapper kappes hieß da glaube ich der hat der hat immer nicht datenbanken gesagt und datenbanken der hat datenbanken immer so geil
ausgesprochen
Wobei ist der kappes ich glaube ich glaube schon
Ja bei uns auch aber der hieß halt so
Kenne ich nicht die gab es die gab es zu meiner zeit in der berufsschule noch nicht
Na gut ich wollte ich wollte eigentlich hier noch kurz fertig gucken
Web frameworks and technologies gut react wissen wir note ist auch klar was mich interessiert
Welt das welt ist halt auch immer echt interessant ja das welt ist kaum gefragt
Noch aber das ist stetig steigen von jahr zu jahr aber es ist ultra beliebt es wird nur aus irgendwelchen gründen von phönix noch getoppt
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal
Warum war was an phönix so toll ist noch nie noch nie benutzt noch nie gesehen und auch bis jetzt keine
Versuchung verspürt mir das anzugucken
Warum ist warum ist phönix so pock warum ist das so beliebt
Das ist vollstärk javascript oder
Lxc oh nee please da habe ich keinen bock drauf ich will das schon in der programmiersprache machen die ich kenne
Ich will das schon in der programmiersprache machen die ich kenne
Sind da irgendwelche php sachen drin die wir gestern auch ausprobiert haben
Laravel braucht keiner aber viele finden es ganz brauchbar
Naja kann man sich drüber streiten
Mich hat es nicht so geschockt gestern
Symfony
Ähnlich bedeutungslos
Ja aber gut
View, React, Angular
Das ist das ist klar
React, Angular
Warum ist
Angular ist weniger
Designed als Welt
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
Ganz vieles im Business Enterprise Umfeld
Ist Angular
Fast API
Was ist Fast API
Für ein Framework
Javascript Node oder was ist das
Fast Python
Ich dachte da machen alle Flask oder sowas
Python okay
Lit
Gachi
Das ist auch php hier
Das finden die Leute kacke und es braucht
Keiner
Das Play Framework weiß ich nicht mal
Was das sein soll
Was ist das Play Framework
Java
No
Damit fangen wir erst gar nicht an
.NET ist beliebt
Vollkommen zu recht
Admired
70%
Ich würde es
Genauso unterschreiben
Das .NET Framework
Ist mit die beste Standard Library die ich kenne
Da kann
Go nicht mithalten da kann Python nicht
Mithalten da kann Ruby nicht mehr
Mir fällt keine andere Programmiersprache ein
Java weiß ich nicht ehrlich gesagt
Die ein so gutes komplettes
Standard
Standard Library Standard Framework hat
Wie .NET
Was fällt euch ein
Go hat auch viel
Aber
Oftmals aber ein bisschen rudimentär
Alles Python hat auch viel
Aber auch nicht so wirklich immer
In der Tiefe wie man es braucht
Welche Sprache hat noch so ein gutes Standard
Framework wie .NET
Mir fällt wirklich keine ein
Also das hat Microsoft wirklich gut gemacht
Okay .NET Framework
Will keiner mehr haben auch zu recht
Und wer jetzt denkt
Ich hab es ja schon oft genug gesagt
Wer jetzt etwa denkt das .NET 5
Was mit .NET Framework
4.8 zu tun hat als Nachfolger
Der irrt es hat nichts miteinander zu tun
Heißt bloß ähnlich
Ja gut mit Springboot hab ich endlich gesagt noch nichts gemacht
Aber Spring ist ja eigentlich nur für
Webanwendungen oder? Also das ändert ja
Nichts an der Standard Library von Java
Und das stimmt C Sharp ist die
Bessere Sprache
Also ich bin immer begeistert was es alles gibt
Multithreading in C Sharp
Ist die richtige Kombination aus
Einfachheit und
Möglichkeiten
Du kannst in C Sharp
Entweder
Easy Async Sachen machen
Oder Async Multithreaded
Und sowas also
Das ist gut integriert im Framework
Und auch was du an standardmäßigen Klassen dabei hast
Du hast mittlerweile sogar einen brauchbaren HTTP Client
Der könnte noch ein bisschen besser sein
Weil ich finde
Er ist mittlerweile okay
Der Standard HTTP Client
Von .NET aber
So richtig geil ist er nicht
Zumal es immer noch ein bisschen
Mehr deutliche Sachen gibt
Es gibt HTTP Client
Es gibt Web Request
Und sowas manche Sachen haben sich halt in .NET
Die letzten 20 Jahre über
Ein bisschen parallel entwickelt
Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen
Sie haben jetzt große Fortschritte
Mit ihrer
DateTime API gemacht
Die letzten Versionen auch ähnlich wie JavaScript
Du hast alles was du brauchst dabei
Also .NET
Link dürfen wir nicht vergessen
Ist wirklich top
Und dazu kommt
Das ist halt eine richtig gute Kombination
Bei .NET
.NET hat eine super Programmiersprache
Mit C Sharp
Wenn ich auch sage die letzten paar Jahre über
Also ich freue mich jedes Jahr über die neuen Releases
Von C Sharp und ich finde es auch gut
Dass sie das jährlich machen
Ich würde mir wünschen sie würden mal zwei Jahre
Stopp machen mit neuen Features
Aber sagen wir mal so
Sich auf zwei, drei richtig
Community gefragte Features
Konzentrieren
Und die anderen
Aufräumen
Das fände ich in C Sharp mal ganz gut
Zum Beispiel was ich mega nice finden würde
Das ist auch eines von der Community am meist nachgefragten
Features ist
Dass es mehrere Return Types
Geben kann
Da gibt es jetzt schon
Implementierung auf GitHub
Als Class Library
Allerdings
Integriert in die Sprache wäre das nochmal
Cooler
Es wäre schon nice wenn es quasi so
Einen Art Union Type oder sowas
Geben würde
Dass du mehrere Return Types haben könntest
Das braucht man nicht so oft
Aber wenn man es braucht ist das
Zum Beispiel nice
Warum möchte man in einer Methode
Vielleicht mehrere Return Types haben
Mal ein ganz nah liegendes
Beispiel
Zum Beispiel
Web Requests
So
Ja TypeScript kann das mittlerweile
Sogar C++ kann das glaube ich
Mittlerweile
Malgenommen Web Requests
Ne das gibt es nicht
Auch nicht in C Sharp 8
Zum Beispiel du machst Web Requests
So und der Web Request
Der kann jetzt entweder ein Result liefern
Ein JSON Result
Oder eine Fehlermeldung
So
Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen
Der Standard C Sharp Weg ist
Werf eine Exception
Wenn es eine Fehlermeldung gibt
Aber es muss nicht immer eine Exception
In dem Sinn sein die du dann handeln willst
Es kann ja durchaus sein
Dass du eine JSON Antwort
Bekommst
Oder aber du bekommst
Ein Object Not Found
Ist keine
Keine
HTTP Exception
So
404 ist eine HTTP Exception
Das lasse ich mir gefallen wenn man das Ganze
Über Exceptions macht
Ja aber zum Beispiel
Wenn man eine API hat die dir entweder
JSON Details zu einem Objekt liefert
Oder dir irgendwas leeres
Liefert mit Not Found
Not Found ist keine
HTTP Exception
Sondern ein gültiger Return Wert
Der aber nicht zwangsläufig
Sich zu einem
JSON Objekt serialisieren lässt
Also das ist zum Beispiel
Da kann man das wunderbar benutzen
Wenn du Methoden hättest die mehrere
Return Types haben können
Und das fände ich extrem nice
Wenn ihr das in .NET einbauen
Zumal .NET die letzten Versionen über
Oder gerade C Sharp die letzten Versionen über
Auch viel funktionaler
Geworden ist das fängt mit Pattern Matching an
Das geht mit Rekord Types weiter
Und auch vieles im Standard Framework
Von Objekt Bildern
Und sowas das ist deutlich
Oder die ganzen Immutable Classes
Und sowas die es jetzt gibt
Das ist deutlich mehr funktionaler geworden
Die letzten
Die letzten paar Versionen
So .NET hat einen riesen Vorteil
Drei große Vorteile für mich
Als Plattform
C Sharp ist eine super Programmiersprache
Und mit ein paar Sachen die ich mir noch dazu wünschen würde
.NET ist eine super Runtime
Und hat gleichzeitig eine super Standard Library
Und sie haben mit
ASP.NET Core eines der angenehmsten
Web Frameworks noch dabei
Also fürs
Backend finde ich ist das
Echt eines der besten
Technologien die man verwenden kann
Gerade wenn man in Azure in der Cloud ist
Da ist natürlich Native
Alles in .NET unterstützt
Musste gar keine Docker Container bauen
Funktionen rein
Ich glaube die ganzen großen Cloud Anbieter
Können mittlerweile alle auch .NET in Functions
Ja und
Das ist einfach
Das ist einfach eine gute Plattform
Die Microsoft
Da gebaut hat
Ja genau das meine ich
Hat C++ nicht Union Types oder sowas
Sowas hier oder
Ja es ist halt mal wieder C++
Ne Moment das ist ein C Feature
C++ Feature
Ja dann weiß ich nicht wie man es in C++ macht
Juckt mich auch nicht
C++ sagt eh
Was Standard Expected
Was ist das jetzt schon wieder
Ja sowas in der
Richtung
Sowas in der Richtung
Also ich zeige euch mal für .NET
Wie das Leute nachgebaut haben
So
Es gibt zum Beispiel
So eine Library hier für C Sharp
Genau
Du machst eine Funktion hier und in dem
Return Type schreibst du
Das der Return Type
Hiervon ist
Also der Return Type kann sein
Ein User, Invalid Name
Oder Name Taken Fehler
Und für solche Sachen das ist enorm praktisch
Das braucht man nicht oft
Aber wenn man es braucht oder wenn es sich anbietet
Dann ist es enorm praktisch wenn die Sprache sowas unterstützt
Und das wäre
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor die würden das wirklich in die Sprache einbauen
Dann könnte man das sogar syntaktisch
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen schöner machen
Und selbst wenn sie es nur mit einem weiteren
Standard Library Type machen
Wäre es halt wenigstens mal was offizielles
Aber wenn es offiziell ist
Kann man dann auch besseres Compile Time
Checking machen und alles mögliche
Das wäre wirklich
Das ist eines der meist
Gefragten
Was ist Value of
Ja
Das ist eines der meist
Gefragtesten C-Sharp Features
So und ich bin der Meinung sie sollten sich
Auf vielleicht die nächsten paar Jahre
Nächsten 2-3 Jahre mal
Auf wirklich so die 2-3 große
Beliebte Community begehrte Features
Konzentrieren. Aktuell habe ich den Eindruck
Die
.NET
Entwicklerteam bei Microsoft
Die schnappen sich Features
Die ganz cool sind aber einfach umzusetzen
Und bauen davon möglichst viele
Von Version zu Version ein
Nicht dass es der beste Ansatz ist die Sprache weiter
Zu entwickeln
Dazu kommt
Dass die einige Sachen
Die letzten Jahre übereingebaut haben in .NET
Im Framework aber auch gerade in C-Sharp
Als Sprache die ein wenig
Verfeinerung brauchen könnten
Ja
Ich sage nur diese ganze Geschichte mit
Rekordstruct
Rekordclass
Refstruct
Refzeug
Ach was es da nicht alles gibt
So richtig hundertprozentig durchblicken tust du da nicht mehr
Und das ist eines
Der beliebtesten
Oder meistgefragten
Features überhaupt
Du bist ausgestiegen bei
Nullable
Warum die Nullable eingestiegen
Übrigens Leute an der Stelle
Ich habe gehört wenn man auf
Über 300
Twitch Subs kommt dann kriegt man wieder
70-30 Share
Ich werde demnächst auch mal einen Subcounter einführen
Und ich muss mehr
Sellout machen
Ich brauche
Ach fuck du hast recht
Es sind 300 Non-Prime Subs
Davon bin ich weit entfernt
300 Prime Subs also mit Primes kriegen wir hin
Aber
Mit ein bisschen Sellout
Aber ich glaube 300 Non-Prime Subs
Da muss ich schon
Also da müsste ich wirklich
Ich streame ja schon regelmäßig
Und halt auch meistens
Nicht so richtig
Und vor allem halt auch
Nischen Sachen
Ich werde mit meinem Technik gebastelt
Hier auf Twitch nie 1000 Viewer
Oder so erreichen
Danke Leute für die Sub
13 wieder am Start
PotatoBob
PogSubs
Ich glaube wir sollten echt mal einen Subs
Machen demnächst
Eigentlich gar kein
Für die Subscriber ist der Unterschied
Das der Prime Sub nichts kostet
Wenn sie einen Prime Account haben
Den kann man halt einfach so mitnehmen
Wenn man einen Amazon Prime Account hat
Für mich macht es auch keinen Unterschied
Ob Prime Sub oder normaler Sub
Der einzige Unterschied ist
Das Twitch anbietet
Wenn du 3 Monate in Folge 300
Normale Subs, Paid Subs hast
Kriegst du wieder 70-30 Share
Aber nachdem ich das hier nicht mache
Um reich zu werden
Eigentlich interessiert es mich nicht
Auf der anderen Seite
Ein bisschen interessiert es mich natürlich schon
Ich will jetzt hier nichts erzählen
Ich mache das alles
Nur aus reiner Nächstenliebe
Ich mache das hier hauptsächlich einfach
Weil ich Bock habe zu streamen
Oder mich mit solchen Sachen hier zu beschäftigen
Nicht weil ich damit Geld verdiene
Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber trotzdem ganz cool
Dass ich ein bisschen was rauskriege
Für die reingesetzte Zeit
PopOES
Das ist einfach gut zu wissen
Dass wenn ich mich abends nochmal 3-4 Stunden hinsetze
Und stream mache
Dass ein bisschen was bei rumkommt
Soweit ich weiß, dass es ja auch vielen Leuten was bringt
Gerade wenn es hier um
Irgendwelche technischen Themen geht
Ich glaube wir haben schon sehr vielen Leuten hier geholfen
Oder auch bei irgendwelchen
Programmiergeschichten
Wir haben ja teilweise Leuten sogar schon bei den Hausaufgaben
Geholfen im Stream
Donations? Ne Donations mag ich nicht
Subscriptions ist am besten
Ich gucke mir lieber
Subcounters an
Die 8€ sind nicht von alleine bezahlt
Also ich kann euch mal sagen
Wie viele Subs ich gerade habe
Ich glaube ich habe gerade ein ziemliches Tief
Subscriptions habe ich gerade
Ich weiß auch nicht
Das liegt wahrscheinlich an der Jahreszeit
Normalerweise bin ich immer so um
230-250 rumgekrebst
Aber im Sommer ist
Meistens ziemlich low
An Weihnachten geht es dann
Teilweise schon Richtung 300
Aber ich gebe zu
Man könnte halt das auch noch
Viel viel besser machen hier auf Twitch
Also ich könnte meinen Production Value
Wie man es so schön nennt, den Stream noch deutlich
Steigern, wenn ich mich mal
Ein bisschen mit beschäftigen würde
Wie man ordentlich streamt
Ähm
Und
Ich könnte das natürlich auch alles noch
Ein bisschen besser ausnutzen
Ich meine damit nicht Placements
Ich könnte noch regelmäßiger Sellout machen
Und irgendwelche
Da gibt es tatsächlich Möglichkeiten
Aber habe ich eigentlich keinen Bock drauf, bin ich viel zu faul für
Ne habe ich nicht
Ja bist du nicht der Erste
Wobei ich das nicht finde, aber ja
Das kenne ich
Ach Quatsch, kick alter
Das Ding ist bald wieder weg
Vielleicht bleibt es bestehen als
Seite für Gampling Content
Für Gampling Content und
NSFW Content
Den Twitch nicht haben will oder so, keine Ahnung
Wie es sich jetzt entwickelt, aber ich glaube nicht
Dass es ernsthaft zu einer
Game Streaming Konkurrenz
Zu Twitch wird
Morgen erstes Bewerbungsgespräch als
Linux Systems Engineer, nice
Bist ja das gleiche wie ich
Zumindest von der Job Bezeichnung
Ich bin auch Linux, ne ich bin nicht
Linux Systems Engineer, ich bin nur Linux Engineer
Weil warum eigentlich, weiß nicht
Außerdem ist es auch vollkommen egal
Was man als Job Titel hat
Ne das war
Das war nicht Kick oder
Das war
Ne ne ne, das war You Now
Oder so was es gab
Damals
Oder wie das hieß
Was dann direkt
Wieder dicht gemacht hat
Wenn ich das
Noch in Erinnerung habe
Ne glaube ich nicht
Du hast gesehen wie das mit Ninja
Und Mixer lief, Hitbox gab es auch
Genau
Das glaube ich nicht
Die streamen dort nur durch Geld
Die sind relativ schnell wieder da
Sobald Twitch
Sobald das ausläuft
Ich glaube nicht
Also ich kann es mir nicht
Vorstellen, soweit es für mich
Aktuell so aussieht, als geben die einfach massig
Geld aus von irgendwelchen Risiko
Kapitalgebern und dann machen sie dicht
Es sei denn sie bleiben bestehen
In der Form von
Ne Gambling Stream sein
Ich kann es übrigens wirklich nicht verstehen
Also ich will es keinem schlecht reden, wenn er es gerne guckt
Sollen sie machen ja
Aber ich persönlich kann es nicht verstehen
Der Reiz an Gambling Streams
Ich finde das so
Unglaublich langweilig und
Und
Wie soll ich sagen so
Langweilig und
So shady
Sodass ich mir irgendwie so gar keinen Bock habe
Anzugucken
Mir fällt ja kein richtiges Wort für ein
Ich habe überhaupt gar kein Verlangen
Dazu irgendwelche Gambling Streams zu gucken
Aber das ist ja teilweise richtig
Mega beliebt ja
Und ich verstehe nicht warum
Ich bin ja wahrscheinlich zu alt für
Ich habe auch nie Case Openings
Oder CS
Skin Unboxings und so Zeug geguckt
Ich habe das
Ich habe den Reiz davon
Oder FIFA Pack Openings
Ich habe den Reiz daran noch nie verstanden
Ich kann es mir irgendwie
So halbwegs zusammen reiben
Warum die Leute das gucken
Aber ich kann es persönlich nicht nachvollziehen
Also dafür bin ich null empfänglich
Was Gambling angeht
Also real Gambling
Mit echtem Geld und so
Was ich machen kann ist
Path of Exile spielen und Crying
Das ist ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen Gambling
Hast du schon mal Lotto gespielt?
Okay
Wenn du mich so fragst, ja habe ich
Ich glaube einmal
Vor 25 Jahren
Oder so
Da bin ich mit meiner Mutter Lotto spielen gegangen
Und jeder hat so ein paar Kästchen ausgefüllt
Das war irgendwie mal so ein super
Mega krass Rekord Checkpot
Da sind Leute Lotto spielen gegangen
Die nie Lotto spielen gehen, wir auch
Aber ansonsten, ich spiele nichts in der Richtung
Keine Lotto
Keine Losgeschichte
Das einzige
Und deswegen kann ich vielleicht ein bisschen nachvollziehen
Wo ich als Kind
Total drauf gestanden habe, waren so Lose
Auf irgendwelchen Messen und so
Kennt ihr das noch, wo irgend so ein Typ
Auf so einem Stand steht und sagt im Motto
Jedes Dritte los gewinnen, gewinne, gewinne, gewinne
Und dann übelst einen Hype macht
Und da so Lose
Auf der Dippe messen oder so
Oder auf irgendwelchen
Messen und so, da stand ich richtig drauf
Aber das lag daran, wo ich klein war
Musste ich die Lose ja auch nicht selbst bezahlen
Da bin ich immer
Mit meinem Vater da hingegangen und
Das war noch zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo der fett Kohle
Verdient hat
Und da hat er immer die Lose rausgehauen wie sonst was
Und ich hab quasi immer was gewonnen
Deswegen fand ich das geil, aber warum hab ich
Immer was gewonnen, weil der Typ halt massig Kohle
Reingebuttert hat und ich hab teilweise
Auch Lose getauscht und sowas mit Leuten
Für mich war das so eine komplette Tagesaufgabe
Wir haben dann Lose gekauft
Da bin ich dann da rumgelaufen und hab die Leute gefragt
Wollen wir tauschen? Wollen wir tauschen?
Ich geb dir drei Stück davon, wenn du mir zwei Stück davon gibst
Ja, das hat mich richtig gehypt
Damals
Aber was so Glücksspielsachen angeht
So klassische Casino-Gamplingsachen, da bin ich
Null empfänglich für
Das ödet mich und langweilt mich nur an
Und ich verstehe auch nicht, wie man sich das anguckt
Aber auch so Sachen wie
Skin-Gampling und sowas
Wirklich, es juckt mich gar nicht
Ihr müsst euch das angucken
Die Games, die ich spiele, wo es Skins gibt
Wo man vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen Gameplay gesehen hat von mir
Ich ändere nie meine Skins
Ich spiele ein bisschen
Dann hab ich so ein paar 0815 Skins
Irgendwann equippe ich mal einen
Und der bleibt dann für die nächsten 20 Jahre eingestellt
Mich schocken Skins nicht
Selbst bei Overwatch
Hatte ich mehr oder weniger
Immer die gleichen Skins ausgewählt
Es gibt so einen Skin, der gefällt mir am besten, fertig
Ich mach noch nicht mal kostenlose Gewinnspiele mit
Ich hab auch keine Rabattkarten
Ich hab nichts in der Richtung
Hast du eigentlich jemals über Freelancer
Beziehungsweise Karriere als Selbstständiger nachgedacht?
Ja, hab ich
Und wisst ihr, zu welchem Schluss ich gekommen bin, Chat?
Ich glaube, ihr kennt mich
Mittlerweile gut genug
Warum will ich das nicht?
Ist ganz einfach
Weil es mir zu anstrengend ist
Ihr habt es richtig erkannt
Genauso ist es, Chat
Das ist mir einfach zu anstrengend
Okay, damit könnte man
Wahrscheinlich noch mehr Geld verdienen
Und ich meine, ich verdiene schon echt nicht verkehrt
Ja, muss man ja auch mal dazu sagen
Aber könnte man noch mehr Geld verdienen
Aber es ist auch viel anstrengender und viel verantwortungsvoller
Da hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
Und noch mehr Steuererklärung und alles mögliche
Okay, das Risikoreich
Wäre vielleicht gar nicht so das Problem
Aber
Das ist mir zu anstrengend
Kein Bock drauf
Das
Das Poker-Prodigy hier
Bei mir sind echt
Geld bezahlte Lootboxen
Verboten. Ey, wo lebst du? In Belgien?
Oder
Wo ist das verboten? Mir fallen da nicht
Viele Länder ein. Belgien ist das, glaube ich, verboten
UK
Hat irgendwas in der Mache
Ist aber, glaube ich, noch nicht durch
Ahja, Belgien, okay. Ja, weil von Belgien
Hab ich das auch gehört. Aber ganz im Ernst
Wahrscheinlich umgehen die das bei euch doch mit irgendwelchen
Tricks, oder? So nach dem Motto
Ah, das sind jetzt keine Lootboxen
Mehr, sondern das sind jetzt irgendwie anders
Benannt und man weiß halt
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit im
Vorfeld und
Du hast feste Drops, aber
Die Schlüssel kosten noch
Die umgehen das doch garantiert irgendwie
Trickreich. Aber
Es gibt in Belgien keine
FIFA-Packages zu kaufen
Okay, das sollten
Tatsächlich echt noch mehr Länder machen
Ich meine, man muss sich mal
Vorstellen, es gibt Leute, die kaufen
Sich FIFA quasi im Early Access
Nenne ich es jetzt mal, so im Super-Premium-Paket
Zwei Wochen Headstart, um
Dann tausende Euro für auszu...
Okay, das ist vielleicht übertrieben. Hunderte
Euro dafür auszugeben, vor allen anderen
Packages einlösen
Zu dürfen. Das ist so
Also
Diese FIFA-Geschichte habe ich nie kapiert
Aber da bin ich
Zu Boomer für wahrscheinlich
Ja
Ich habe mir auch noch nie ein FIFA-Game gekauft
Ihr wisst, Fußballspiele sind nicht mein... Wobei das stimmt nicht
Meine
Meine Xbox One war
Gebundelt mit FIFA, das war ein FIFA-Bundle
Das ist das einzige FIFA-Game
Was ich hier noch habe
Nie gespielt, nie eingelegt, nie
Ausgepackt
So, lass mal gucken. Komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal ein paar Videos
An
Was haben wir denn hier
Ich hab gesehen
Der Maurice hat ein neues Diablo-Video
Das wollte ich gucken, das habe ich noch nicht geschaut
Diablo 4 hat keine Ausrede
Für absurde Shop-Preise
Mein falsches
Die Sachen von Maurice habe ich bei der
Gamestar schon immer mega gerne geguckt
Und
Eines meiner Lieblings-Five-Heads
Äh, nee. Native-Web
Äh, Programmierer
Und Entwicklungs-Channels
Auf YouTube hat er heute Morgen auch wieder ein Video hochgeladen
Aber 23 Minuten ist mir einfach zu krass
Jetzt, ey. Die beste Architektur für deine Software
Okay
Ich finde, der Kerl macht wirklich gute Videos
Hier
Der bringt die Sachen oftmals gut auf den Punkt, die man sich eh schon
So im Hinterkopf immer so denkt
Aber
Der formuliert das meistens dann auch ganz gut aus
Und sagst, ja, genau das habe ich mir auch schon oftmals so
Am Rande überlegt, aber ich bin da nicht so
Drauf gekommen
Ja
Das finde ich auch gut
Okay
Was wird uns denn wieder empfohlen? Ja, okay
Die Shorts sind wieder richtig pepega
A man's most powerful tool
Okay, soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Das Gehirn
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es da drum geht
Pass auf, da kommt jetzt das Gehirn
It's the ability to
Ja, ja
Wie?
Nee, anklicken tue ich das nicht
Ja
Anklicken tue ich das nicht
Dann bin ich ja in die ganze
Pepega-Geschichte reingefallen hier
Nee
So Digger klicke ich nicht an
In der Hoffnung, ich kriege gescheite
Shorts empfohlen
Jetzt kriege ich gar keine Shorts mehr empfohlen, doch hier
Interessieren mich aber
Things to stop doing when it's been
Moment, wir sind hier Informatikor
Programmierstellstream, wir reden prinzipiell
Nicht mit Frauen
Gibt's in der IT eh nicht
Next
Berufsschule abschaffen, jawoll
Ich kann mein eigenes Video für Viewtime gucken
Analytics sind schon durch
Nee, ich klicke da nicht drauf, keine Chance
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Diablo 4
Devops is terrible
Was ist das denn?
Ah, R natürlich, was sonst?
Ich wollte eigentlich noch das Heimautomatisierungsvideo
gucken, was
Spiel und Haus, nee
Spiel und
Spiel und Zeug
heißt da, genau
Euer Smart Home Beispiel
Devops ist auch terrible
falsch gemacht
Und streng genommen sind eigene Devops Teams
eigentlich falsch
Wenn man den klassischen
Devops Ansatz nimmt
Aber gut, ich mein, so hat es sich halt mittlerweile etabliert
Menschentiere Automationen
Jawoll, zeig her, da bin ich immer
Lass ich mich immer
inspiren von
Ups
Oh jetzt wird's aber advance
Das bräuchte
ich für meine Haustür
Wenn die Katze davor sitzt
dann erkenne ich das und dann lass ich die Katze rein
oder raus, ich mein, ich hab ne Katzenklappe
eigentlich brauch ich das überhaupt nicht, was erzähl ich da
für nen Blödsinn, genau dafür hab ich
eigentlich ne Katzenklappe
Ihre Griffstellung kontrollieren, Lichtschranken, Balkonbewässerung
Garten klingeln
Heute geht es um Inspiration, rund um smarte
Möglichkeiten für draußen
Ich schau immer an, was ihr gebaut habt
gebe meinen Cent und 50 Euro
für jede gezeigte Automation dazu
Ihr könnt euch kostenlos inspirieren lassen
und ich fülle diesen Kanal mit einem weiteren Video
für das ich fast nichts
tun musste, Menschentiere Automation
Ausgabe 19, los geht's
Du musst es schneiden, reacten drauf
und hochladen
Ich glaube mit 50 Euro macht er da schon
Minus, pro Einsendung
Na wobei, wobei, ja doch
sind irgendwie 8 Einsendungen oder so
Aber macht nix, insgesamt dafür nicht
Und es bringt
dick Views und Reichweite
Ich gucke die Dinger immer gerne
Automatisierte Sandkistenabdeckung
Okay, das sieht schon sehr
gebastelt aus
Aber cool, dass es funktioniert
Es sieht für mich so aus, übrigens, als hat
das auch oben drüber noch ein Dach
Seht ihr hier unten die Pfeiler?
Das hat doch oben drüber noch ein Dach
Okay, das Prinzip habe ich verstanden
Okay, hier gehen so Schnüre hoch
Die ziehen das Ganze hoch
Ja, okay
Laufen da über irgendwelche Rollen
Und
Da ist doch noch ein Dach drüber hier oben
Kann mir doch keiner was anderes sagen
Ein Markisenmotor, okay
Guck mal, hier oben drüber ist doch noch ein Dach
Warum muss man das jetzt abdecken, wenn da noch ein Dach drüber ist?
Dass von der Seite
nix reinkommt, oder? Aber so viel kann das doch nicht sein
Ich muss sagen, ich finde das schon ganz gut
Aber, ja, gut gebaut
auf jeden Fall
Es kann dann im Zweifel auch noch irgendwie Windschutz sein
Damit keine Katzen
raufgehen aufs Klo, okay
Das würde ich sogar noch verstehen
Ja, okay
Ja
Chat, ihr habt mich überzeugt, macht Sinn
Fantastisch, also gerade wenn ich dran denke
wie oft wir nicht dran denken
die Abdeckung abends drauf zu machen
und am nächsten Tag darf ich dann Katzenkacke
aus der Sandkiste sieben
Ah, okay, daran liegt's
Die einzige Frage, hast du das irgendwo
Ich darf auch täglich Katzenkacke
hier rausziehen
Wo ist das Problem?
Ich schiebe meine Kackteile in den Klo, der dafür da ist
Dran gekoppelt, irgendwie
ein Präsenzmelder oder sowas
Der dürfte dann natürlich
nicht von der Katze getriggert werden
Sonst öffnet sich
das paradiesische Klo ja dann automatisch
Aber schreibt ihr gerne in die Kommentare
wenn ihr Ideen habt, wie man das Ganze
idealerweise triggern könnte
Carsten hat geschrieben, dass das alles
einigermaßen selbsterklärend ist, und ich würde sagen
technisch ist es das, also
Er hat auch geschrieben, dass er das mit Loxonen umgesetzt hat
Aber am Ende ist ja
Das kannst du ja mit allem umsetzen
Du brauchst einen Motor
und irgendwas, um das ein- und auszuschalten
Das ist tatsächlich relativ easy
zu bauen, wobei es
nicht so einfach ist, das zu bauen
dass es reliable funktioniert
Aber an sich, rein von
den Komponenten dürfte es relativ
einfach sein
Also es reicht dir ja schon jeder x-beliebige
Microcontroller
Und der Motor muss ja auch nicht viel können
Da brauch ich ja auch nicht viel Leistung
in der Motor, um so ein paar Hölzchen
da zu bewegen
Völlig egal, du musst irgendwie diesen Motor ansteuern
Ich hab gerade überlegt, ob wenn der hier zufährt
ob nicht vor diese Rollen
noch so kleine Handfeger gebaut werden sollten
Das der abputzt
Die den Sand vom Rand wieder nach innen fegen
Das wäre zumindest bei uns
eine willkommene Ergänzung
Das macht auf der einen Seite
den Rollen
den Weg frei, und auf der anderen Seite
führt es den Sand zurück, dahin wo er hingehört
Ich glaube, mein Opa
hat ja auch gerne gebastelt und gebaut
Der hat total viel am Haus hier selbst gemacht
Ihr kennt ja noch den selbstgebauten Fahrstuhl
den mein Opa gebaut hat
Wenn mein Opa nicht so computer- und technikfeindlich
gewesen wäre
Der konnte damit halt überhaupt nichts anfangen
Aber der war halt auch schon alt
Und würde der heute noch leben
Also wäre der ein bisschen aufgeschlossener gewesen
Und würde der noch leben
Der könnte enorm viel Spaß mit Heimautomatisierung
und gebastelt haben
Das wäre genau sein Ding
Mein Opa hat schon Heimautomatisierung und Sachen
gebastelt, da gab es das Wort dafür noch gar nicht
Das wäre genau sein Ding
Da hätte er mega Spaß dran
Leider ist der halt so
technikfeindlich gewesen
Aber auf jeden Fall sehr schön, wenn ihr auch smarte
Automationen für eure Wohnungen, Häuser und Gärten
gebaut habt
Wer baut schon 1900, was weiß ich, wann die das
gebaut haben, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 1960
oder so, wer baut
einen eigenen Fahrstuhl
an einer Stelle, wo du eigentlich gar
keinen Fahrstuhl bauen kannst
Also das war schon
ziemlich sick, was der Opa da gebaut hat
Guck mal hier, wer den nicht kennt
Boah, keine Ahnung, wie das Video
hieß, Baustelle
Ja, hier
Fahr ich hier hoch?
Ne, da ist schon die neue
Klappe drin
Dachbodenstelz, jawohl
Jetzt hier, hier sieht man es
Hier bin ich schon oben
Guck hier
Guck, das hat mein Opa selbst gebaut
Das ist ja alles schon ein bisschen kaputt, weil wir hier
am Umbauen schon waren, am Hausrenovieren
Aber guck mal, das hat mein Opa selbst gebaut
Du bist da hingegangen, so
Hier neben sieht man ja schon die
Wie nennt man das, diese
Schienen für den Fahrstuhl
So, und dann hast du hier einen Knopf neben
Ja, ich hab das alles ein bisschen pepega gefilmt
Normalerweise war hier unten auch noch ne
So ne, so ne Bodenplatte
Dran, dass es bündig abgeschlossen war
So
Und dann drückt man hier den Knopf
Was ich jetzt nicht zeige
Weil ich blöd bin
Drückt man den Knopf, da kommt hier so ein Wagen runtergefahren
So
Dann muss man hier rein
Und wichtig ist
Man musste das hier wieder zumachen
Das hier musste man zumachen
Ansonsten ging es nicht los
Da hat er eh nen Kontakt
Wenn es nicht richtig geschlossen war, konnte man nicht losfahren
So
Und jetzt konnte man da drauf drücken
Und dann konnte man hochfahren unter das Dach
Also wir mussten den Fahrstuhl
Leider entfernen, weil du das Dach
So absolut nicht dämmen konntest
Es war undämmable
Quasi
Jetzt haben wir ne Treppe
Aber der Fahrstuhl war schon enorm
Alles weg?
Ja, alles weg
Der Fahrstuhl war schon enorm
Ich glaube, ich zeige das auch
Irgendwann, wie der Fahrstuhl von hinten
Hier, guck mal
Das ist der Motor
Ja, ich hätte das mal ordentlich aufnehmen sollen
Alles 30 FPS
Billiges iPhone
Guck mal, hier hat er so einen Seilzug gebaut
Das ist halt übersetzungsmäßig
Ein bisschen mehr Kraft hat alles
Hier unten ist ein Motor drin
Und hier geht das halt rüber mit so nem Stahlseil
An den Fahrstuhl draußen
Und er hängt da dran
Das ist die Konstruktion ja auch
Vom Ansatz her easy
Aber das hat er alles selbst gebaut
Und das schon vor 100 Jahren
Naja, nee, nicht ganz
Aber vor
50 Jahren
Nee, noch mehr
Vor 70 Jahren oder so hat er das gebaut
Oder vor 60 Jahren
Ist lange her
Das musste er auch erstmal alles machen
Und auch das mit den Schienen und die Elektronik
Das ist jetzt nicht ohne
Vor allem, ey, das ist noch aus ner Zeit
Da gab es keine Microcontroller
Das ist alles
Analoge, manuelle Schaltung
Und sowas, dass das funktioniert
Somit, ich hau mal kurz
ESP32 ins WLAN
Der mit nem Relay dann irgendwie
Den Motor triggert da oben
Nee, nee, das war damals nicht so
Heute wär das einfacher gewesen
Ja
Ja, eigentlich schade, dass der Fahrstuhl weg ist
Aber cool
Hier hatte mein Opa sein Atelier
Gehabt, sieht man leider nicht so viel
Weil das Video
Wo ich das Atelier gezeigt hab
Das musste ich löschen auf YouTube
Wisst ihr warum?
Weil mein Opa
Gerne nackische
Mädels gemalt hat
Und das war MonkaToss
Für YouTube
Der hat zig Akt
Bilder oder wie nennt man das
Also so nackt Portraits
Von Models
Die Probe gesessen haben
Dort gehabt
Oder gibt's
Das Video, nee, das Video gibt's noch
Das Video gibt's noch
Guck mal
Mein Opa war richtig, richtig, richtig
Richtig künstlerisch
Begabt hier, guck mal
OH GOD
Fuck, kann ich euch nicht zeigen
Moment, geht das mit VLC?
Lasst mal kurz was probieren
Geht das mit
YouTube DLP?
Mal ausprobieren
Ach das kann man runterladen
Okay
Achja, das funktioniert
Also ich kann euch nicht das komplette Video zeigen
Weil wie gesagt
Das sind keine Fotos oder sowas
Das sind von meinem Opa gemalte
Also
Portraits, nee ich bin nicht Portraits
Wie nennt man das
Also Ölbilder
Aber halt mit
Nackischen Mädels als Motiv
So
Und guck mal
Hier sieht man noch
Hier war das mit dem Fahrstuhl
Ihr seht hier war das oben noch nicht abgerissen
So und
Jetzt geh ich erstmal hier
In das andere
Mal rein, da sind keine
Nackischen Frauen auf Bildern drauf
Da hat er sich
Ja
Der konnte auch wirklich gut malen
Wir haben auch ganz viele Bilder von dem hier
Im Haus hängen, vom Opa
Ja klar, die hab ich alle behalten
Okay, nice, Rollstuhl
Äh, ja okay Max
Das interessiert keinen
Ach guck mal, hier sieht man tatsächlich den Motor
Mal ordentlich vom Fahrstuhl
Hier
So sieht das aus, was er da gebaut hat
Und nebenbei
Steht irgendwie noch ne Flasche
Was auch immer, wahrscheinlich ne Flasche Öl
Oder so, okay Max weiter
So guck mal, hier gibts Bilder
Also der hat richtig
Abgedrehtes Zeug gemalt
Also nicht nur hier so alter, alter Mann
Am See, guck mal
Der hat auch
Also ich weiß, dass mein Opa
Sehr beschäftigt hat
Damals
Damals mit der Atombombe im 2. Weltkrieg
Da hat er einige Bilder zu gemalt
Sieht man glaub ich hier auch irgendwo
Guck mal hier, das Rechte
Also der hat da auch ein bisschen so
Seine, seine
Kriegserfahrung verarbeitet, ne
Das ist schon krass, was der gemalt hat
Okay
Ihr sehts ja auch mit
Naja, also wenn das jetzt
Also wenn das Ölgemälde nur hier Toss ist
Dann weiß ich auch net, ja
Also man siehts ja auch hier mit Atombomben, Explosionen und sowas
Also richtig
Richtig hart, was mein Opa da von sich
Von sich
Gegeben hat in Bildform, ja
Richtig, richtig krass
Ja
Also auch von Motiven her
Das gehört übrigens zusammen, ja
Also das ist, falls
Ihr das nicht erkennt, also das ist richtig, richtig
Richtig Six Head
Das sind 3 Bilder, die gehören zusammen
Das ist vorher
Das ist bei der, das ist während
Der Atombomben-Explosion und das ist nachher
Also das ist richtig
High IQ, was da mein Opa fabriziert hat
Alter Mann
Am See und
Hier hat er sich
Mit irgendwie, Menschen werden
Geklont beschäftigt und sowas
Guck, das ist irgend so ein
Geklontes
Baby und so, wo die ganzen Forscher
Drumherum stehen und so, also er hatte schon
Coole Motive, so auch
Wie sagt man, so ein bisschen so Fantasy-Motive
Und sowas, also schon
Also er hatte es schon drauf
Muss man sagen, ja
Und die habe ich natürlich alle behalten
Und es hängen auch viele, okay
Das mit der Atombombe hängt jetzt nicht bei mir im Wohnzimmer
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu
Das drückt vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr
Aufs Gemüt
Wenn man das im Wohnzimmer sich angucken müsste, ja
Aber die habe ich
Die habe ich alle noch
Schon hart, oder? Also mein Opa hat es richtig
Drauf gehabt
Wo soll ich denn jetzt gucken?
Wie zum Teufel
Bin ich eigentlich
Von
Heimautomatisierung
Auf Bilder von meinem Opa jetzt gekommen
Achso, dass mein Opa viel Spaß
An Heimautomatisierung gehabt hätte
Was man ja auch am Fahrstuhl sieht
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder, genau
Also die anderen
Bilder will ich euch nicht zeigen, weil die sind halt
Noch deutlich mehr
Explicit, was er da
Gemalt hat
Ich meine, der hat nicht nur nackte Frauen gemalt, mein Opa
Aber der hat schon viele nackte Frauen gemalt
In allen
Nur erdenklichen
Posen und Winkeln
Ich bin ja
Wisst ihr eine Sache, die ich mich
Wo ich mich heute immer noch
Frage ist, wie hat das
Wie hat das geklappt? Weil
Die Bilder hat er alle gemalt
Als er aus dem Krieg wieder
Daheim war, schon
40 Jahre
50 Jahre
Und über die nächsten 50 Jahre hat er die gemalt
Was hat meine Oma
Denn dazu, genau das frage ich mich
Auch, das habe ich
Mich auch schon gefragt
Was hat meine Oma dazu gesagt
Dass im Atelier
Bei meinem Opa
Nackte junge Frauen gesessen haben
Die viel
Jünger waren als er, wohlgemerkt
Der war damals ja
Wenn er die Bilder gemalt hat, der wird sicherlich
Wahrscheinlich angefangen, so in meinem Alter
Der hat schon früher angefangen zu malen
Aber sagen wir mal so, der war so in meinem Alter, vielleicht
Und der hat da 20 jährige Mädels
Rumsetzen gehabt, die für ihn
Model gestanden, okay, vielleicht
Ganz im Ernst
Das war halt rein künstlerisch
Ja, also
Wahrscheinlich hat sich da keiner Gedanken drüber gemacht
Ne, da ist nix
Da ist nix gelaufen
Wisst ihr
Ganz im Ernst, ich glaube
Wenn du damals gesagt hast, ich bin
Maler
Und
Wollen sie Modell stehen für mich
Da haben die Leute noch nicht gedacht
Alter, das ist ja bestimmt voll der Perverse
Der will mich einsperren
Unterm Dach
Das wäre heute mein erster Gedanken, den ich wahrscheinlich hätte
Wenn mich jemand anspricht, also
Mich spricht eh keiner an, ja
Aber wenn ich 20 weiblich und gut ausschauen würde, ja
Und mir spricht jemand an
Ich bin Maler, möchten sie für mich Modell stehen
Dann würde ich heute denken, Alter
Bestimmt übelst gestörter
Massenmörder, der mich jetzt in irgendeinem Container
Einsperrt
Und damals haben die Leute sich gedacht
Oh ja, nice, warum nicht
Aber gut, ich glaube
Damals hat man sich da auch mehr gekannt
Und man wusste ja auch, der war ja hier auch in der Hanauer
Künstlergilde und so
Und ich glaube, das war schon ein bisschen mehr
Schon ein bisschen
Bekannter, ja
So, gucken wir mal weiter
Ja, aber wie gesagt, also ich habe viele Bilder
Von meinem Opa hängen, wir haben
Also hier bei mir im Arbeitszimmer
Habe ich tatsächlich keins hängen
Das ist aber der hauptsächliche Grund, weil
Weil das immer so unordentlich alles ist
Hier, ja, und Kartons
Und sonst wie, und dann müsste ich
Abstauben und alles
Hier hängt keins, aber sonst hängt
Außer im Bad und in der Küche
Fast in jedem Zimmer und im Flur
Hängen Bilder
Meistens eher so die
Naturmalereien vom Opa, ja
Wo er dann irgendwelche
Österreichischen
Berge oder so was
Also wie gesagt, die etwas
Die etwas
Ja, tiefer
Gehenden Bilder von den Motiven her
Ich, wie gesagt
Also ich brauche im Wohnzimmer
Kein Bild mit einer Atombombe hängen
Aber man sieht schon, der hat sich einiges
Gedacht dabei, was er gemalt hat
Okay, jetzt gucken wir erstmal fertig
Chat, jetzt mal ernsthaft
Meinte ich soll das Wort, jetzt mal seriously
Meinte ich soll das Wort löschen
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das unter
Toss fällt, Ölgemälde vom
Opa, mit
Wo man halt minimal Buba sieht
Also
Das wäre wirklich lächerlich, wenn das
Toss wäre, das ist ja kein
Porn, das sind Ölgemälde
Vom Opa
Aber bei Twitch weiß man halt nie
Ja, da musst du dir irgendeinen Amorant
Pool-Stream angucken
Und schon hast du mehr Buba als da
Okay, weiter gucken
Dann schickt die gerne ein unter
Zeug.cool.slash zeigen, könnt ihr mir das zukommen lassen
Und wie gesagt, für jede gezeigte Automation
Gibt es 51 Euro Amazon-Gutschein
Und vielleicht
Bekommen wir ja noch irgendwie, weiß ich nicht
Eine Balkon-Kraftwerks-Edition dieses Jahr zusammen
Oder eine mit Sachen rund ums Auto
Oder
Nochmal Garten und Bewässerung
Der Sommer ist ja dank Jahrzehnten
Verfehlte Energiepolitik
Die ist auch auf Kick oder was?
Okay, okay
Seriously? Seit wann ist denn die schon nicht mehr auf Twitch?
Moment
Kurzer Buba-Check
Alter
What the fuck
What the
Alter
Das ist erlaubt?
Was zum Teufel
Seriously?
Das ist erlaubt?
Okay, okay, warum nicht
Alles klar
Ich glaube die Leute sind hauptsächlich
Wegen des Gameplays da
Komplett normal
Na gut
Alle nur Gameplay-Enjoyer
Dort im Stream
Darfst doch auch als Kerl so da hocken
Ich glaube nicht, dass ihr das wollt
Das glaube ich nicht
War es nicht so
Dass Bikini und leichte Bekleidung
Eigentlich nur noch in Nähe von
Von Pools und so
Eigentlich erlaubt war
Ja, okay, okay
Mich wundert es nur
Ich hätte eigentlich nicht gedacht
Dass das im Einklang mit Twitch-Toss ist
Nicht so, dass sie sich im Bikini hinsetzen
Sondern breitbeinig mit
Knapper Hose da vor die
Ich meine, es ist doch klar, wo der Fokus
Dieses Streams liegt
Oder? Ich meine eindeutig auf dem Gameplay
Gucken wir weiter
Sicherlich noch lang
So, Sören hat ein vollautomatisiertes
Garagentour via Lichtschranke
Mit Geofencing
Unser Garagentour ist ein bisschen spezieller
Funktioniert über eine Lichtschranke
Für die Ausfahrt
Und über Geofencing fürs Öffnen
Ich fahre jetzt also hier entsprechend
Aus der Garage raus
Auto geht aus der Lichtschranke raus
Ein paar Sekunden Zeitverzug
Schließt sich jetzt entsprechend
Da hast du recht, da habt ihr
Chat, da hast du voll und ganz recht
Das ist sicherlich nicht gewollt
Das passiert nur im Hirn der Leute
Das ist nicht
Sinn und Zweck gewesen
Garantiert nicht
Das ist reine Wahrnehmung
Der Zuschauer
Das Garagentor
Geht zu, man fährt seines Weges
Und dieser Zustand
Ich meine, die Webcam steht halt
Nur zufällig zwischen den Beinen
Das kann doch mal passieren
Wenn ihr wüsstet, wo meine Webcam gerade steht
Ja
Wird jetzt entsprechend gespeichert
Das heißt, wenn das Haus weiß, das Auto ist nicht da
Das Handy kommt zurück in den Geofence
Dann geht entsprechend das
Garagentor auf
Jetzt habe ich gar nicht geguckt
Also was ist mit dem Garagentor
Ich fahre jetzt also hier entsprechend
Aus der Garage raus, Auto geht aus der Lichtschranke raus
Ein paar Sekunden Zeitverzug
Schließt sich jetzt
Entsprechend das Garagentor
Und geht zu, man fährt seines Weges
Und dieser Zustand
Wird jetzt entsprechend gespeichert
Das heißt, wenn das Haus weiß, das Auto ist nicht da
Das Handy kommt zurück in den Geofence
Dann geht entsprechend
Das Garagentor auf, wenn man sich nähert
Sodass man damit überhaupt
Nichts mehr zu tun hat
Einzige Lücke ist jetzt zum Beispiel
Man hat das Auto in die Werkstatt gebracht, kommt ohne Auto wieder
Chat, also ich nicht
Glaubt mir, weil mir will das keiner sehen
Aber es
Erstaunt mich und das muss ich
Jetzt einfach mal sagen, weil ich da letztens
Darüber gestolpert bin
Nicht nur
Uber-Streamerinnen haben
Onlyfans
Und Webcam-Kram
Ich war letztens bei einem
Recht bekannten Speedrunner, einem Mann
Auf Twitter
Und da war
Ein Onlyfans-Account verlinkt
Also
Es sind nicht nur Mädels
Mit Onlyfans-Account unterwegs
Mittlerweile
Und das war
Ein ziemlich bekannter Speedrunner
Und
Das war auch kein
So Troll-Onlyfans
Also das war wirklich
Hardcore-Onlyfans
Doch war es
Nein, es war nicht Simply
Ob Simply einen hat, weiß ich nicht
Aber es war ein recht bekannter Speedrunner
Das hat mich echt gewundert
Aber nein, nicht nur
Uber-Stream-Mädels haben Onlyfans
Gibt auch einige Typen, die Onlyfans haben
Soll jeder machen, wie er will
Auf der Plattform ist das ja auch
Normaler Content
Ja
Und wem das gefällt und wer dafür Geld ausgeben will
Why not?
Ja, Simply sitzt auch in Twitch
Das stimmt schon, aber den meine ich nicht
Der sitzt in Twitch auch immer oben
In der Webcam immer
Ich frage mich nicht, wie wir auf diese Themen gekommen sind
Chat, lass mal von was anderem reden
Heimautomatisierung
Ja
Geht halt trotzdem das Garagentor auf
Ich würde es eigentlich irgendwie gerne an ein AirTag
Koppeln, dass man den quasi ins Auto packt
Dass es dann wirklich am Auto hängt
Und hier noch die entsprechenden Lichtschranken
Das ist immer so ein Ding mit AirTag
Habe ich mir auch schon überlegt
Oder anhand der GPS-Position
Das Ding ist, wenn du dann vor deinem Haus
Vorbei fährst, geht auf einmal
Die Garage auf
Oder das Hoftor auf
Das willst du ja nicht unbedingt
Du willst eigentlich nur das Hoftor aufmachen, wenn du wirklich auf den Knopf drückst
Das heißt
Ich bin ja immer noch am überlegen
Ob ich mein Hoftor ausstatten soll
Mit zwei
Wie nennt sich das so schön?
Torantrieb oder so
Ich habe mir
Sogar schon welche gekauft
Dafür
Habe ich sogar im Stream schon mal ausprobiert
Ich habe sogar schon ein Relay dran zum schalten
Und alles, aber ich habe es noch nicht installiert
Von Hörmann
Ich glaube, nee Sommer
Sind meine Antriebe von Sommer
Kannst du in den ESP32 an die Autobatterie klemmen
Und dann?
In was für einem Anwesen, Mondmax?
Naja, in einem etwas größeren Kunststück
Mit Haus drauf und einem Hoftor
Irgendwie musst du ja reinkommen in den Hof
So
Und
Ich habe mir das auch überlegt, ob ich das über die GPS
Das Hoftor
Vom Innenhof, genau
Also Hoftor zur Straße hin
Hoftor zur Straße hin
Und dann fährt man in den Hof rein
Und ich habe mir überlegt
Ob ich das mit den GPS-Koordinaten mache
Aber dann geht halt das Hoftor auf, wenn man mit dem Auto vorbeifährt
Und
Ich werde es jetzt wahrscheinlich so machen
Sollte ich das Hoftor in der Art behalten
Und das mit Antrieben ausstatten
Ich werde das mit einem Knopf machen
Ja
Mit einem Knopf, was entweder
Von einem ESP-Empfang
Beziehungsweise halt
Einen WLAN-Knopf, ja
Übers WLAN-Authentifizierung macht
Oder über LoRa oder sowas
Oder
Ähm
Das wollte ich jetzt sagen
Oder, genau, jetzt war ich es wieder
Oder über Carplay
Über Carplay
Ist auch noch eine Möglichkeit
Weil über Carplay kann ich einfach
Ein
Home Assistant-Button quasi
Ins, über
Wie heißt das Ding? HomeKit glaube ich
Über, quasi als HomeKit-Button
Exportieren und das dann über Carplay
Auf dem Autodisplay
Anzeigen und ich glaube, dass das
Die beste Variante ist
Über Carplay
Das Ganze zu machen
Allerdings auch nur Carplay im WLAN, weil
Nun ja, ich will ja nur, dass es nur geht
Wenn ich daheim bin, nicht aus Versehen
Da drauf drücke und dann geht das Hofdrauf
Kann man auch noch an die GPS-Koordinaten
Koppeln und sowas, ja
Eher so sieht es aus, ok, weiter
Weiter gucken
Auf einer Seite zwei Lichtschranken
Auf der anderen Seite
Wiederum zwei Reflektoren, die darüber
Quasi merken, ob das Auto da ist
Aussteigen und aufmachen
Naja, die einfachste Variante ist immer noch
Die Fernbedienung vom Hersteller nehmen und da auf
Drücken
Da geht es auch auf, das ist das Einfachste
Uh, ja, also
Zwei Sachen
Also das mit Airtex wird glaube ich nicht funktionieren
Das ist zu träglich
Was der Vorteil ist
Ähm, eigentlich
Kein Vorteil
In Form von, dass du weniger brauchst
Sondern nur, dass du halt einen festen
Platz hast, wo das Ganze ist
Dass du es nicht irgendwie am Schlüssel mittragen musst
Oder sowas
Oder du hast halt einen festen Knopf im Auto
Wo du draufdrücken kannst an irgendeiner Stelle
Eher so eine Komfortgeschichte
Nicht so sehr, dass es irgendwie
Weniger Teile bräuchte
Ja, easy
Warum? Einfach direkt Chauffeur
Und gut ist
Wege für deinen Anwendungsfall
Und wie oft bringst du denn das Auto
In die Werkstatt? Also ich
Für meinen Teil
Ich hab es erst letztens in die Werkstatt gebracht
Weil Firmware-Update
Tief in der Automatik
Die haben ewig gebraucht, ne
Ich war da, Firmware-Update
Für's Auto
Und das hat
Zwei Stunden gedauert, bis es fertig war
Also ich geh mal davon aus
Bis ich es wieder mitnehmen konnte
Nee, Fiat, Fiat 500e hab ich
Und
Das hat zwei Stunden, konnte ich es wieder mitnehmen
Alter
Nee, kann man nicht selbst flashen
Weiß nicht, was die
Also ich weiß nicht, ob die einfach nur lahm sind
Oder ob Fiat Firmware-Update so lange braucht
Ja, der Fiat kann das auch
OTA machen, aber du kannst
Nicht alles OTA updaten
Du kannst das Entertainment-System und sowas
OTA updaten, aber du kannst zum Beispiel
Nicht die internen Sachen für, keine Ahnung
Bremsen und sowas OTA updaten
Uftor Champ
Wie ich mir das wünschen würde
Aber ich für mich fände es okay, wenn das Auto
In die Werkstatt kommt, die Garage
Wieder manuell zu schließen, indem ich das
Irgendwie in meinem Handy
Wieso hast du kein YouTube-Premium? Ich hab YouTube-Premium
Die sage oder auf
In der App da drauf drücke oder so
Oder du machst das
Über die Lichtschranken
Wenn das aufgefahren ist und nach 15
Minuten noch nichts da in der
Lichtschranke steht, dann fährst du
Das Auto mal
Wir haben Kekl-Steer nicht aktualisiert
Nicht aktiviert
Das ist irgendeine
Addon-Geschichte, die da Max
da verwendet, keine Ahnung wie
das zustande kommt, das ist Emote-Kekl
Und dann noch mit
Steer als Zusatz
Wie macht man
Wie macht man das denn?
Kekl und dann Steer
Ach so funktioniert das
Okay, easy
Das ist quasi kein
Emote, das wird dann nur Overlaid
Ne, ich bin nicht eingeloggt bei YouTube
Deswegen steht das nicht da
Aber ich hab privat auch YouTube-Premium
YouTube-Premium
über Indien abgeschlossen
Mit nem zweiten Account
Weil's billiger ist
Das ist ne gute Kombination
So, next, ich muss gleich ins Bett
Oder du baust dir noch ne Lichtschranke
In den Vorgarten, wobei das wahrscheinlich
Zu kurz vorher ist, ne?
Sonst wär vielleicht ne Möglichkeit das Ganze
Irgendwie in HomeKit zu bringen und dann per
E-Mails in die Mobile-App, nein
Keine Chance, es sei denn du hast Android
Und benutzt nen alternativen Client, dann geht das
Das einzige Emote
Das einzige animierte Emote, was du
Benutzen kannst auf
Auf Mobile ist
WhoopPad und WhoopPad 2
Die gehen Mobile
Weil sie offizielle Twitch-Emotes sind
Leute, ich hab noch so viele Emotes
Ich muss echt mal wieder
Neue Emotes reinpappen
Kenn deine Handysituation nicht
Und deine Autosituation, aber wenn das Auto
So oft in der Garage ist, vielleicht hat es auch noch kein CarPlay
Da würde aber ja sonst auch
Ne kleine Taste auftauchen, jedes Mal, wenn du dich
Deinem Zuhause näherst, dass du mal eben
Die Garage aufmachen kannst, wäre natürlich nicht
Vollautomatisch, dann haben wir von
Volker eine Meer-Tiefgarage
Für Worx Rasenmäher
Bekommen, wir sehen hier schon sein
Okay, das sieht HIQ aus
Er startet jetzt eine manuelle
Fahrt seines Worx
Meer-Roboters, schauen wir mal rein
Die Musik
Die Musik, Alter
Das ist natürlich
Schon ganz gut
Jetzt mal sehen
Oh, und das ist offenbar auch
Sehr gut koordiniert, der fährt
Relativ sofort los, wenn er hochkommt
Außer du hast da einen sehr gut gesetzten
Schnitt drin
Und dann fährt er zu
Holy Luck Gamers, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub
Mit welcher
Webcam von
1928 hast du denn dieses Video
Das ist eine gute Gelegenheit für mich
Mal auszuprobieren, ob ich das
Per AI hochgerechnet kriege, also wenn das
Bei euch gar nicht mehr so schlecht aussah
Dann habe ich AI
Hochrechnung von Videos ausprobiert
Ja man sieht, man sieht aber
Dass es AI hochgerechnet ist, weil das
Hier so komisch flimmert drum herum
Das heißt Leute
AI hochgerechnet, das bedeutet
Auch wir sehen hier Gras, was gar nicht wirklich da
Ist, es ist ja nicht wirklich
Hochgerechnet, sondern es ist Sachen
Hinzu erfunden
Also je nachdem, was er benutzt hat
Es könnte auch wirklich einfach nur
Hochgerechnet in dem Sinn sein, dass
Versucht wird halt ein bisschen das ordentlich zu
Upscalen, aber so richtig
AI Enhancement
Erfindet halt einfach Gras dazu, wo kein Gras
Ist und sowas
AI Upscale vom ersten Video
Obendrauf liegt, weil das ja schon eine
Sehr kleine Grasnarbe wäre
Also gerade wenn der Garten nicht so super groß ist
Aber cool ist es schon gemacht, oder?
Das ist natürlich schon eigentlich
Eine sehr elegante Geschichte
Und dein Kunstrasen passt
Sehr gut zur
Optik des restlichen Rasens
Außer der restliche Rasen ist auch Kunstrasen, dann bräuchtest
Du allerdings keinen Meerroboter
Mich hat natürlich noch ein bisschen interessiert, wie du die gebaut hast
Wie das ganze
Aufgestellt aussieht
Könnte man wahrscheinlich auch oben
Einfach noch ein bisschen mehr Grasnarbe drauflegen
Und echten Rasen
Ja
Musst du natürlich auch regelmäßig hochfahren
Also Meerroboter ist für meinen
Garten einfach nicht das
Viel zu viele Wurzeln, viel zu viele
Beete und Pflanzen und Unebenheiten
Und
Ich glaub das funktioniert nicht gescheit bei mir
Dann müsste man die Grenzen
Irgendwie markieren
Sowas hier quadratisch und klare Grenzen
Ist halt easy
Auf jeden Fall sehr schön, vielen Dank dafür
Ja, bei neuen nicht, aber die funktionieren nur mit
China-Chinesen-App und haben Batterien
In den Begrenzungssensoren
Das ist auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache
Damit die Tiere heute nicht zu kurz kommen
Habe ich von Luis
Ein Katzenfenster bekommen
Hallo, heute zeige ich euch unser Fenster
In der Garage
Das ist ein ganz besonderes Fenster
Es kann nämlich automatisch auf und zu fahren
Es liegt daran, dass wir eine Katze haben
Und diese mussten wir damals
Immer noch durch die Tür rein und raus lassen
Wenn diese raus wollte
Doch als das zu nervig wurde, haben wir uns gedacht
Wir haben ja eine Verbindung
Vom Haus in die Garage
Über eine Katzenklappe
Moment, ihr habt eine Verbindung
Vom Haus in die Garage über eine
Katzenklappe, müsst ihr dann aber
Aus der Garage, warum hattet ihr denn da
Eine Katzenklappe?
Wahrscheinlich weil die schon vorher da war
Dubios oder unvollständig
Aber ich lasse das für jetzt erstmal durchgehen
Und durch dieses Fenster kann
Die Katze ganz einfach zwischen
Den Gitterstäben hindurch
Nach draußen gelangen
Die Gitterstäbe haben den Vorteil, dass wir das Fenster
Einfach immer geöffnet lassen können
Und auch
Kein Einbrecher von außen reinkommen kann
Wegen den Gitterstäben
Außer seine Katze
Das heißt, die Katze kommt hier auf das Brett
Über die kleine Treppe hier drauf
Wird von dem Bewegungsmelder
Erkannt
Und das Signal wird über die Kabel
An diesen Mikrocontroller weitergegeben
Und das funktioniert zuverlässig?
Eben, der dann
Letztendlich diesen Motor hier ansteuert
Und mit diesem Stahlseil
Also ich habe schon gemerkt
Nicht alle Bewegungsmelder erkennen Katzen
Zuverlässig oder sagen wir mal so
Ähm, erkennen Katzen
Oft richtig
Also mal nicht
Mal schon
Gibt bestimmt auch gute, wo das funktioniert, aber
Manche sacken
Dafür richtig
Ich würde sagen, die meisten sacken dafür
Das Fenster öffnet
Auch Stahlseil scheint
Mir hier ein bisschen geschmeichelt
Das ist doch eher ein Stahldraht
Oder ein Stahlfaden
Jetzt sei mal nicht so
Nicht so überkorrekt hier an der Stelle
Kann man doch durchaus Stahlseil nennen
Jetzt sitzt da oben eine Feder, die das Fenster
Durchgehend randrückt
Das sieht aber krass
Gebastelt aus, oder?
Was mir ja prinzipiell gefällt
Seil dann einfach wieder abgerollt wird
Und dann schließt sich das Fenster wieder
Der Bewegungsmelder
Ist eigentlich nichts anderes
Als so ein billiges
Bewegungsmelderlicht
Doch das Signal kann super dazu genutzt werden
Den Mikrocontroller
Zu sagen, dass der Motor
Sich drehen soll
Da ist eine Stimmdose dran
Die ist einfach nur dazu da
Um das so ein bisschen zu fokussieren
So, jetzt habe ich es auch schon aufgemacht
Das Fenster fährt auf
Reagiert auf jeden Fall recht flott
Jetzt dauert es einen Moment, die Katze kann rausgehen
Sie soll ja auch nicht
Zerquetscht werden
Er hat übrigens die guten
Wasserdichten Boxen, die es im Dutzend billiger gibt
Ab und zu bei Amazon
Habe ich mir auch schon öfters gekauft
So ein Zwölferpack von solchen Boxen
Für so Elektro
Zwischen
Verkabelungsdinger
Für Elektrosachen
Abzweigdosen, genau
Aber die sind wirklich praktisch
Die haben mehrere Ausgänge, sind
Ein bisschen elastisch, kann man auch einfach was rausschneiden
Sehr angenehm
Und die kosten teilweise nur
60 Cent das Stück
Kann man immer mal so ein Zwölferpack bestellen
Und dann fährt das Fenster wieder zu
So, und damit dann aber nicht
Folgendes passiert
Ich würde mir Gedanken machen, wenn der Schwanz der Katze
Im Fenster ist
Es geht ja relativ
Langsam zu, also das sollte die Katze
Eigentlich schon checken
Wobei, Chico checkt ja eigentlich
Nichts
Die Katze sitzt oftmals noch
Draußen auf dem Brett
Damit dann aber das Fenster nicht auf und zu und auf
Und zu fährt, ist dann eine kleine
Sperrzeit von circa 20 Sekunden
In der Zeit passiert nichts
Und dann haben wir hier noch zwei Knöpfe
Über die kann ich das Fenster einmal manuell
Auf und zu machen
Und wenn ich diesen Schalter hier umlege
Kann die Katze, so jetzt geht es nochmal auf
Kann die Katze von außen rein
Mir fehlt jetzt noch
Dass wir die Katze mal sehen
Ich habe eigentlich gehofft
Wir können uns noch seine Katze angucken
Aber nicht mal von drinnen
Nach draußen
Ah, das ist quasi so für nachts
Was wir zum Beispiel machen
Wenn wir zum Tierarzt müssen
Weil dann eine Katze reinkommen würde
Aber nicht mehr nach draußen abhauen soll
Gute Idee
Außer sie versteht wie die Kippschalter funktionieren
Sonst kann sie sich auch selber das Fenster aufmachen
So, hatten wir schon mal zumindest indirekt
Ein Tier
Ja, die meisten Katzen sind ja gechippt
Dann bräuchte man so ein Lesegerät
Aber vielleicht überrascht uns ja noch irgendwo
Aber da müssen die Katzen dann relativ nah dran sein
Ein weiteres
Für alle, die keinen festen Anschluss haben
Ich habe das Ganze
Mit einer großen 9 Liter Gießkanne
Und einer Gardena Urlaubsbewässerung gelöst
Die Gießkanne deshalb, weil es deutlich schöner aussieht
Als ein Plastikbehälter
Ja
Die Pumpe lässt sich einfach durch eine smarte Steckdose bedienen
Verteilt wird dann das Wasser über ein Schlauchsystem
Welches normalerweise nur aus einzelnen Schläuchen besteht
Für den Schlauch
Reicht ein normaler PT Schlauch aus dem Baumarkt
Und Tropfer gibt es von Gardena
Oder günstig im Internet
Die Pumpe schiebt sich leider produktionsbedingt
Nach einer Minute automatisch ab
Ah, quasi so ein Bewässerungssystem
Für die Sachen auf der Terrasse
Da sie eigentlich dafür vorgesehen ist
Oh, die ist hübsch
Durchgängig am Strom zu sein
Und immer alle 24 Stunden
Einmal für eine Minute zu laufen
Muss man in HomeKit über die Deaktivierungsfunktion
Die Steckdose ausschalten
Um sie dann für die nächste Automation
Wieder starten zu können
Das wäre ganz interessant
Das kleine Ding bewässert einfach stumpf
Alle 24 Stunden nach dem Einschalten
Und das ignorierst du
Indem du einfach
Also in meinem Fischteich
Habe ich auch eine Pumpe drin
Wobei ist das eine Pumpe?
Die macht so Wassersprudelzeug
Wie nennt man das?
Pumpe
Und die schalte ich auch über eine Steckdose
An und aus
Die läuft morgens von 7 bis
7.30 bis 10.30
Abends von 17.30 bis 20.30
3 Stunden
Umwälzpumpe, ja kann sein
Da ploppert es auch immer
So ein bisschen Luft raus
Das ist ganz praktisch
Weil dadurch im Winter
Das nicht so leicht zufriert
Weil es in Bewegung ist
Steckdose ausschaltest
Und dann wieder anschaltest
Wenn du sie brauchst
Okay
Um das letzte Loch in unsere
Automatischen Bewässerung zu schließen
Das sind dann vor allem die Kübel vor der Haustür
Die sind nämlich nicht Teil
Der automatischen Bewässerung
Das ist vielleicht auch eine Idee
Also wenn ihr vielleicht auch Bewässerungen habt, die abgekoppelt vom Wassernetz
Funktionieren
Das bräuchte ich nicht
Ich habe eh nicht so den
Wie sagt man? Grünen Daumen was das angeht
Juckt mich nicht
Das höchste der Gefühle war
Dass ich mal so
Feuchtigkeitssensoren ausprobiert hab
Dass man weiß, wann man wieder gießen muss
Aber die Dinge haben auch
Gesagt
Vielleicht mit Zisternen oder so
Da bin ich für die Zukunft im neuen Haus auch sehr interessiert
Zeug.cool.slash zeigen
Cornelius hat sein Fensterkontakt versteckt
Es geht offenbar um das Problem
Dass ein Türsensor
Der oben an die Tür geklebt ist
Aber der Griff trotzdem
In der einfach
Aufdruckstellung sein kann
Ja
Das
Verstehe ich
Ich kann mir vorstellen, wie der das gelöst hat
Der hat den Sensor einfach
An den Türgriff gepappt
Und den Sensor hier unten hin
Das ist das Einzige, wie man das einfällt
Wie man das mit einem Sensor machen kann
Wobei man dann nicht weiß
Ob das Fenster wirklich zu ist
Man geht aber einfach mal wahrscheinlich von aus
Weil die andere Seite anliegen muss dafür
Weil ich das ja schon von einigen gesehen hatte
Die das mit 2 machen
Türsensor im Fensterrahmen
Okay
Und dann hast du den Magneten
Auf das
Was ist das?
Ja genau
Okay, ist ähnlich zu dem, was ich gesagt habe
Er hat es an das Verriegelungssystem gemacht
Aber
Kunst es dann überhaupt
Ah, das slidet hier vorbei
Hier hängt sich das ein
Ist ähnlich vom Ansatz her
Also
Ist ja wirklich einfach gemacht
Ich weiß nicht, ist das der Magnet aus dem Teil?
Nee, nee, nee, nee
Das ist ein
Gekaufter Magnet
Der
Bei dem Sensor sieht anders aus
Kannst ja bei Amazon im 40er-Pack kaufen
Das ist ein eigener, ne?
Du hast einfach irgendwo einen Magneten besorgt, einen kleineren
Den da drauf gepackt
Aber gute Idee
So kleine Sachen ist das, was einem oftmals das Leben erleichtert
Ich muss sagen, ist ziemlich genial
Du hast nicht die sichtbare Warze
Außen an der Tür
Du hast die genaue Position
Also du hast nicht die genaue Position
Aber er unterscheidet dann eben je nachdem
Wenn du ihn genau ausrichtest
Zwischen die Tür ist offen und die Tür ist geschlossen
Und er zeigt auch offen an
Wenn der Bolzen noch oben ist
Wenn ihr jetzt losgeht
Und in Massen Acara-Sensoren kauft
Ich hab noch welche
Dann macht das gerne über den Link in der Videobeschreibung
Ein 200 IQ-Move
Ja, aber richtig
Adrian hat ein Video
Passend heute zum HiIQ-Stream
Geschickt, das heißt halbwegs smarte Terrassen klingeln
Und ich nehme auch halbwegs smart
Für den Garten ist heute
Wir hören hier draußen
Einfach die Klingel nicht
Wie hab ich das gelöst?
Naja, das Problem hab ich nicht mehr
Weil mein Telefon klingelt einfach
Das Handy und das Festnetztelefon
Wenn es draußen klingelt
Das ist easy
Und eins davon hat man eigentlich immer dabei
Mit einem Megafon am Klingeltrafo
Die Klingel selbst
Ist relativ dumm
Das ist einfach ein kleines Funkteil
Das zwei Empfänger mit Steckdosenbetrieb hat
Und wenn man drauf drückt
Dann klingelt es über Funk
Im Haus sieht es dann so aus
Hier ist einer von den Empfängern
Die man einfach an eine Steckdose anschließt
Eigentlich erstaunlich dumm
Diese Dummheit kann man sich zunutze machen
Im Set waren nämlich zwei von diesen
Empfängern mit dabei
Und eine hängt im Haus
Und dann hab ich gedacht, häng ich den anderen in die Garage
Dann hören wir auch auf der Terrasse
Wenn es klingelt
Und? Weiter?
Das ist ja noch easy
Logisch, aber jetzt noch nicht so richtig
Eine smarte Automation
Irgendwas, Lösung
In der Garage sieht es dann so aus
Hier hängt der Empfänger
Das ist nicht jedes Mal zu belästigen
Da krappeln irgendwelche Viecher rum
Sobald jemand bei uns klingelt
Habe ich dann diesen kleinen Zwischenstecker dazwischen gesteckt
Ah, die gucken wenn die Terrassentür auf ist
Oder sowas
Und der geht nur an
Auf der Terrasse befindet sich dieser Bewegungsmelder
Der Bewegungen erfasst offensichtlich
Nachts schaltet er das Licht an
Und tagsüber
Schaltet er die Zwischensteckdose
Meine Gegensprechanlage ging übers Telefon
Aber das habe ich wieder ausgebaut, das habe ich nie benutzt
Schaltet die Zwischensteckdose an für 20 Minuten
Sobald er Bewegungen erkannt hat
Okay, das lasse ich durchgehen
Das ist tatsächlich eine ganz gute Idee
Weil ja logischerweise gerade eine Außenklingel
Willst du nicht die ganze Zeit
Wie gesagt, am besten ist wenn es Handy klingelt
Das hat man eh dabei
Und das habe ich auf Vibrationsalarm
Das wird dann auch nicht mal die Nachbarn stören
Wobei ganz ehrlich, ab und zu mal mein Handy klingelt
Das werden die schon aushalten
Dafür muss ich
Schreiende Kinder und andere Dinge aushalten
Also insofern, das werden die schon überleben
Wenn niemand draußen ist
Um nicht die ganze Nachbarschaft damit zu nerven
Äh, sehr schön
So, Harald hat seinen Briefkasten geschickt
Ich bin mir nicht sicher
Was uns jetzt erwartet
Ich dachte Briefkästen haben wir so ein bisschen durchgespielt
Aber wir gucken mal rein
Hallo Andreas, also mein intelligenter Briefkasten
Funktioniert mit einer Blinkkamera, wie man hier sieht
Mit anderen Dingen meine ich zum Beispiel
Sowas wie Hühner, einer meiner Nachbarn hat Hühner
Die manchmal auch
Auf dem Zaun flattern und dann bei mir im Hof rumlaufen
Mit Kamera sogar
Funktioniert mit einer Blinkkamera, wie man hier sieht
Leider sind Blinkkameras halt kacke
Okay, das hatten wir bisher nicht
Wenn ein Brief eingeworfen wird
Bekomme ich auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad
Eine Push-Benachrichtigung
Und das Video vom Inneren des Briefkastens
Gute Idee, gefällt mir
Ist wahrscheinlich
Deutlich simpler
Es gibt keine Sensoren, ob der Deckel geöffnet wird
Und sowas, finde ich gut
Was ich mich frage ist
Wie gut kommt WLAN
Aus dem, ist das gesetzt
Warum nicht, der filmt das Innere von seinem Briefkasten
Wo ist das Problem
Was ich mich frage ist
Wie gut kommt das WLAN da raus
Und wie macht er die Stromversorgung damit
Auf neue Post gesetzt
Das funktioniert über
Das ist eine gute Idee
Vielleicht auch für andere Anleger
Das hat ja den Vorteil, dass wenn irgendjemand
Einfach das
Bitte keine Werbung einwerfen Schild
Ignoriert und du da einfach einen neuen Pizza-Flyer hast
Du dafür jetzt nicht extra dahin gehen musst
Du kannst dann ja schon sehen, was du da rein bekommen hast
Ja, nicht schlecht
Und Harald hat mit einem 30 Sekunden Video
50 Euro verdient
Das macht einen Stundenlohn von
600 Euro
Stimmt doch, oder
Wenn ihr irgendwas noch so kleines habt
Schickt es einfach her
Dann schafft es das vielleicht ins Video
Ah, ich gucke die Videos immer gerne
Ist immer einiges an Inspiration dabei
Ihr hast ja gesehen, er filmt seinen Briefkasten
Von innen
Gut, der Moment, wo er die Klappe runter macht
Wäre theoretisch möglich, dass mal mehr
Gefilmt wird, aber da kräht doch
Kein Hahn danach
Ich hab auch an der Eingangstür eine Kamera
Die theoretisch
Minimal ein bisschen was vom Gewicht aufnehmen könnte
Aber ich nehme halt nichts auf
Ich gucke da halt drauf, wenn es klingelt
Daher hat sich auch noch nie einer
Beschwert
Okay, Leute, bad good time, würde ich sagen
Schön, dass ihr heute Abend noch mal mit
Am Start wart
Meine Kamera speichert auch nichts
Wir sehen uns dann die Tage
Vielleicht sogar morgen schon
Bis dann, macht's gut, see you